[Music]
you made it weird with pete holmes
what's happening weirdos this is an
incredible chat with the charming and
delightful and hilarious john heater who
so many of us like may know from
napoleon dynamite also shout out to my
new friend michael rosenbaum who put us
in touch uh he has a great podcast as
well that you should check out that i'll
be on very soon as well so this is how i
got in touch with john our first
latter-day saint uh guest i was very
excited to talk or is there you know
known on the streets mormons very
excited to talk to him and some really
interesting stuff about his career as
well so let's get to it as quickly as
possible uh if you're listening to this
at any point in any time i do a monthly
show at largo go to
largodashla.com for tickets
always always always amazing the last
one had dimitri martin
unblanking oh michael gunger and sean
watkins did music it was really one of
the most incredible shows i'm just
blanking on who else was there because
i'm very deeply tired uh beth's telling
god now i'm only forgetting one person
i'm having a panic attack
but anyway come come see me at largo
once a month largo largodashla.com for
tickets and uh check out if you like the
show and you want to support it try a
pete's pick like our friends at everlane
i'm wearing my everlane jacket deal with
that it's my favorite jacket
and you know what else i love about
everlane is they are a company of
integrity and have wonderful values and
values should guide the decisions you
make throughout your life because when
you stick to what's important to your
very core it shows in everything you do
and evelyn is certainly no exception to
that everlane is committed to doing the
right thing from start to finish that
means partnering with responsible
factories and ensuring every piece of
clothing looks and feels great for years
to come this jacket i have it in blue
denim i have it in black i have their
sweaters these are not only some of the
most ethically made clothes that i own
but they are the best looking and the
best feeling and the longest lasting
they have a dedication to finding
socially responsible factories through
third-party audits with certified
partners they design timeless clothing
with quality materials and a focus on
durability and longevity and they have
transparency and production costs for
every item that means on their site
you'll see what it costs to make which
is really the only place i've ever seen
that they have they are trend proof with
quality made to last that means say
goodbye to unsustainable fab fast
fashion everlane designs timeless closet
staples made with high quality materials
that you can wear over and over again
and frankly that's what i love the most
about them they are
nothing they make is boring but nothing
they make is something like emcee hammer
pants that you can only wear one summer
in 1993. every garment is made from the
finest material like grade a cashmere
italian leather and certified organic
cotton and everlane strive to use the
best materials with the least impact on
the planet so they prioritize sourcing
raw materials from transparent recycled
organic and renewable sources so you can
look good and feel good about looking
good if you want to do things
differently from your core to your
closet shop everlane go to everlane.com
weird and sign up for 10 off your first
order that's 10 off your first order
when you go to
everlane.com
weird and sign up everlane helping
people live their best lives with the
least impact on the planet we are also
brought to us by our friends where is it
where is it
where did it go there it is
[Laughter]
this is
another pete's pick that has been
blowing me away i subscribed i used my
own promo code to subscribe the first
time i tried it because it was
incredibly
high quality and wonderful cbd i know
there are a lot of cbds i know there are
a lot of cbd ads on podcasts but feels
is a premium cbd that will help keep
your head clear and feel your best it's
hassle free and delivered directly to
your door i love it as someone who
suffers from obviously uh occasional
pain nervousness anxiety and
sleeplessness but doesn't want to have
harmful side effects and want something
natural and not pharmaceutical cbd is a
wonderful alternative it naturally helps
reduce stress anxiety pain and
sleeplessness there's no hangover or
addiction i love that it keeps my head
absolutely clear and i never feel like i
need to take it i always feel in control
and you all you have to do is place a
few drops of fields under your tongue
and you feel the difference within
minutes the thing to remember about cbd
is that it's finding your right dose
that's important and everyone's dose is
different what fuels actually has is a
little flight and i got to try three
different kinds and dial in exactly the
right dose or if you're in need of a
dose of chill on the go pop in one of
feels new cbd infused mints for a
clear-headed feeling and bonus fresh
breath in fact fields offers a free cbd
hotline to help guide you
and guide your personal experience
so that you find the perfect dose the
feels customer service team is dedicated
to making sure you get the best use of
your
cbd
joining the fuels monthly membership
makes your self-care so easy you'll save
money on every order and you can pause
or cancel anytime i will attest to that
the subscription discount is enormous so
start feeling better with feels become a
member today by going to feels f e a l s
dot com slash weirdo and you'll get 50
off your first order with free shipping
that's f e a l s dot com slash weirdo to
become a member and get 50 automatically
taken off
your first order with free shipping
that's feels.com
weirdo alright everybody hope you
enjoyed john heater it was such a treat
for me i hope you like it one tenth as
much as i did and then you'll still poop
your pants get into it here you are
you can wear these or not
also i tell this to everybody
get your feet up here look how dirty it
is it's totally fine
bear
bear let's get thank you
oh here we go
now everybody knows it's a falcon it's
like
[Laughter]
that's how to do it man you just did it
it's supposed to be like a sleepover
yeah we're just two bros yeah on a couch
please tell me you've had problems with
people still like you know they sit and
they're like get ready
we've had that a lot
we're doing a bunch of visual stuff
already for our podcast but we got these
camps oh yeah yeah those will be for
clippies and and for youtubies that's
how kids listen to the podcast these
days did you know i didn't know kids
listen to podcasts i don't know if they
do either but
but they're clicking and they're
watching at least the first 30. whatever
counts as a view i don't like i get
caught
yeah well liquid death oh [__] my liquid
death spilled katie no i'm just kidding
it was me i just wanted someone to blame
purely and truly
do you want an ld there's a sponsor
there's a sponsor i
never heard of these until i saw
and we'll get into jamie drinking one
jamie lee yeah my dear friend
what is this is it's just water you then
why are they
lying and sh telling us this is like
caffeinated
i'm like why are we struggling excuse me
we can start to be watching this this is
all good
yo let's get it let's get it that was
pretty good that was very good
there's a
and then i put it buddy um i'm not
forcing it i think these would be pretty
big in the lds commune
like because it's it's not a big booze
i'm super so i like to cool yes and it
makes you look like you're pounding like
a huge 16 is this like a 16.9 67 and
it's but it looks like it's an energy
like a hardcore energy drink right yeah
or with mold liquor in it it looks like
a four loko yeah you throw gold in there
and just like i'm sorry now i'm now i'm
making i keep forgetting i gotta hold it
you don't know we got you you can hold
it at a middle day but i was like why
what's with the what do you call this
kind of font it's that like old english
it's old english which is funny it's the
oldest it's funny that that's a badass
font because the people that wrote that
with big thick feather pens were like
dainty dobbins it wouldn't go well with
lds by the way why murder your thirst we
don't murder
i'm like unlike the other religions
jeez
what do you take us for come on um i'm
sorry but this is another testament of
jesus christ and a lot of people have
murdered in the name of that first book
um wow okay let's get into it
no no no i i i was raised evangelical so
i'm throwing down yes my people saying
the crusades i know that was catholicism
but you know yeah there's been bloodshed
but we're a new we're a new group and
we're a peace loving geez i i'm all into
it it's just
it's just you open it up and you feel
like we are still doing the commercial
and i'm like well you think you're about
to drink something tart
and explosive
that's gonna keep you awake
yeah but really it's just a water group
that figured out that gold
is available for all the people all the
beverages what is what is the catch is
it because it's from straight from the
alps it is good water i'm a i'm a water
snob and aluminum it's like something
preposterous it's like 90 of all
aluminum is still in use did you know
that yeah so plastic bottles this does
not sound like an ab
drink drink uh from aluminum when you
can instead of plastic instead of
plastic okay i mean you still it's still
you just use the same i almost brought
in my reuse regular my regular water
bottle but okay i do want you to say up
top i did not intend to bring up the
church of latter-day saints
this quickly this quickly but i want to
say this
i know well i'm glad yeah sometimes we
have people from the
lesser represented faiths on this
podcast and i always want to say this is
the safest place yeah you are in a
friendly zone we're not even going to
get into it but when it comes up yeah i
just want you to know you can edit
things out and and it's not a gotcha
podcast that's normal no no and i'm also
not an idiot i've been to
provo i've been to salt lake um and and
anywhere in between provo and salt lake
i feel like you really as soon as you
get into american fork or pleasant grove
then that's how you talk about my friend
in the heart so like doesn't almost
count anymore and i'm talking like i
know i don't know i don't go ahead and
represent it yeah i know i don't think i
can represent salt lake provo there's
still a lot of me a lot of my heart left
behind in pro you left your heart
left my in
why why because i went to school there
oh that's why i bring him yeah i love
him yeah yeah i loved my time it's a
great town the mountains i mean there's
a lot of majesty
i'm not even saying those words i think
are in there
the world is our campus and our majesty
or something wow
when you go to utah you do
i think you turned me down a little can
you turn me back up katie because i'm a
narcissist
i'm just kidding i don't care i just
want to make sure i heard me and then i
didn't hear me
this guy's raspberry all over everybody
oh my goodness my coveted raspberry
laughs yeah was it you it might have
been i don't know i'm gonna say whenever
i've been in provo
i look at the mountains and i go like of
course
you felt revelation here you know what i
mean it feels like a very clean
like the frequency to the divine
feelings it's interesting because
they're also known for having the like
the worst air quality index like
around yeah like they're doing all
you're trying to pass all sorts of bills
to clean up the air especially up in
like salt lake that's what i hear and
i'm like that's interesting because i'm
already not a fan of the air that's the
one thing i really don't miss at all
because because of the altitude or
because of the i think because well no
super dry yeah i never used
i never used chapstick in my life until
and then i always carried one around you
go to uh your you go to denver suddenly
you're breaking out that chapstick yeah
it's a non-negotiable then i started
realizing oh yeah just out here in the
mountains like you you need that
chapstick
you need that chappy chap
um is chapstick featured in napoleon
dynamite also something i wasn't yeah
yeah give me your chapstick yeah it's uh
or give me your tots so just give me
your tots which another guy says buddy i
was like ready to not even bring it up
and then you were like
i know but i i like look hopefully
daniel radcliffe's going to do it i'm
going for a harry potter free i don't
see and i'm going for a napoleon sign of
my free a pedigree since and i don't
know
you i mean
i'm with you because he has a very he
has a pretty cool he's done a lot of
very different different things so have
you oh yeah thank you njs
not just saying made it up just now
yes
kind of a bd
let's just say richard oh
oh okay that's not can i tell you this
is what i was going to tell you the
first club i headlined
my whole career was called fat diamond
happies and the guy who ran it
i believe his name was michael
michael b
was a was a latter-day saint i was going
to say mormon but later they say movie
star he made latter-day saint movies you
might even know who he is michael b
michael b
he looks like jack black kind of if he
was wearing i know last night i'm vegan
and you might know who you're with very
much white white blonde hair it's a
strong mite it's a strong might
and i'm pretty sure
when i was there and this would have
been 20 years ago but people were like
yeah and john johnny and right there
they were throwing your name around and
all this stuff but they had movies
called like mormon family night gay
mormon game night excuse me yeah but
they were like
no no family home evening family home
evening that's where you're referring to
or are you talking about the movie oh
okay family home evening is a real thing
that's a real principle but i i think
it's called mormon game night i'm not
sure i should have researched yeah yeah
i don't know but anyway i met a letter
to say movie star and that was one of
the first people i worked for
and he really
he told me a lot of strange things that
i do not think are indicative of the
entire faith but he would tell me like
about his mission and stuff yeah like
finding people that were speaking in
tongues and carving in their arm and
stuff interesting
yeah it was it was very well you like
horror it was very horry but it scared
the the crap out of me because i was
very religious at the time and i'm still
spiritual but i was very religious at
the time and he's telling me these scary
stories about like demons and stuff yeah
and i remember being in my hotel and
being like they're coming they're coming
for me tonight but it's still the
scariest stuff
for me oh of course for me too you know
and i think part of that is my religious
background but like on the mission i
would we i think where was your mission
in japan japan yeah
oh [__]
yeah
wait 18 year old john heater 19 19
forgive me 18 would be crazy yeah or 18
is now now
now they let them go because of modern
revelation
yeah yeah and i don't know exactly all
the reasons why but i think it's just
like get them out sooner or later
no more of this freshman year then go on
a mission
i did a freshman year at byu first then
i went on a mission tell me
everything let's start with your mission
don't jump just to the meat of it tell
me i know yeah you gotta sign japan
i was assigned to so yeah we put in our
papers and i say i'm going to say we a
lot because i have a twin brother did
you go on your mission with him well at
the same time but we had we were
assigned to different missions okay that
would be nice yeah but it was pretty
still miraculous that like we were
called to the same country and we were
both he went to japan too japan too whoa
and when we got the call as we call it
we get the call yeah and normally it's
like this big it's kind of like a
cultural event when you get your call
and you gather your friends and family
around now they do everything on zoom
and they like stream live stream
everything but yeah you don't have
everybody but we had turned it in and we
were still at byu when the papers came
into my folks back at home i grew up in
oregon so this is reference and um
and so my mom was like well you got the
calls i was so excited we were like like
one or two days before we came back home
she's like i'm just opening it now i was
like no
it didn't make any difference
so she's reading to us and she you know
then when they get to the part like you
have been assigned to serve in the tokyo
i heard mine tokyo right away i was like
japan wow i know that and his was nagoya
i don't know nagoya but he was just as
like this is japan yeah we are over the
moon i don't want to put down other
countries but i mean this is what the
the musical book of mormon is about i
did a mission in uganda not a full
mission
that's generous i went on a
three-week mission i was gonna give you
two months but three weeks three weeks
it's not even the same but but the lda
has more missionary system is you know
yeah it's the cadillac of missionary
systems i mean
yeah when i was in uganda i would see
latter-day saints everywhere you're like
there goes the real deal
hey you guys and they're like you want
to know more you're like oh just ease up
ease up take a few steps back
wait mizungu that means he's a white
person oh wow that's what they're saying
in japan see
something only missionaries get thrown
at yeah
and you've got gaijin
yeah yeah and did people call you gaijin
on your mission uh sometimes or they're
just like
baka like which is stupid idiot you know
oh
no normally they thought we were pretty
cool yeah it's like oh
like you're super tall yes well you're a
lean bean yeah okay so you were excited
what i was going to say was the whole
plot of the book of mormon is they get
sent to uganda yeah so there are you can
get sent anywhere in the world you can
and you're 18 or you're 19 you're about
to be 19. you have to admit there's a
human element of like you're going to
one of the coolest cities in the world
well for me so you don't know where
you're going you know you put it and
when you apply you do they want to know
if you study any languages
because but it doesn't always mean my
younger brother studied german all three
he went to germany for like a study
abroad whatever and he got called to
korea so it's sometimes like you have no
idea
but
that is such a funny way to hack your
mission yeah it's just like study you
think french and hope you go to like
french polynesia so i think they like
take but my brother needed this because
otherwise he would have been like of
course germany like he's such a
hilarious yeah he was humbled yeah they
brought him a little humble and we had
studied japanese in high school okay so
i knew there was a chance but i i will
tell you this i was like
look i'll go over where wherever the
lord wants me to go and i will you know
serve the best i can but please i do not
want stateside stateside is when you go
somewhere in the states and and i just i
wanted so badly my father and my older
brother they served in uh chile and uh
el salvador they all joined the brown
spot club which was like oh that's
you for sure if you go south the border
you will crap your pants
you will get so sick at some point and
get a brown spot oh yeah either
uncontrolled or just like a little bit
yeah but nobody's going to watch it you
will soil
the zero on the scale is sharp
like you are sharp on the way it's not
even yeah it's just it's dribbling at
that point a dribble short to three
let's see yeah sure it has like
combustion kind of
propellant this just comes out you don't
even know it yeah like yeah yeah it's
like your car is leaking yes but it was
you yeah it's not oil it's poopoo and
that rhymed and here we are so you
didn't want to go stateside because
you're here's your father and your older
brother both went to christchurch i
wanted to learn another language i
wanted to go
i met people at the temple in salt lake
city and i think they were on their
mission i'm like yeah people serve there
you're you're on a mission it's all
exciting yes and that's almost the one
that you're like oh no but
they get four months in vietnam like you
don't get to you're not going
like captain america wanted to go fight
and it's like you can't go 4a yeah those
are the 4a missions yes those are the
ones
fight the most and then they get sent in
but then everybody comes home saying oh
he's the best of course i'm so happy
uh my brother my youngest brother went
to arizona he's the only one in the
family who didn't go who went stateside
oh no and we were all
we were all like
uh oh
kind of and yeah we were like you know
supportive and of course he said he
loved still had a great time that said
he was like i never need to
go to arizona ever oh he went to arizona
and he was like yeah yeah i never need
to go to
arizona again i'm never gonna eat
another brownie for the rest of my life
i used to ate so many brownies it's a
brownie town it's i don't know brown
it's in the brownies i'm gonna
okay i want to hear everything about
your mission from the very beginning and
who you went with and i do want to say
as a public service announcement be nice
to your mormons uh you know what i mean
like the few times mormons have the
united have come to my door it's like
let's have some food we don't even need
to talk theology like well you can say
you tried i understand yeah let's just
have some snacks let's have some food
cause these are [__] oh they're down
they're down they're down for that
they're down for whatever i mean yes i'm
speaking not for all of them like you
treat them nicely if they treat you
nicely if they're jerks go ahead
slap them go ahead and re-jerk a jerk
but if they're being sweet sweet that's
right i like that re-jerk a jerk go
re-jerk a jerk but i was working as a uh
reenactor in salem massachusetts
different salem i know you have an
association of salem washington and uh
there were mormon missionaries there
and we were we were very close and it
was a really funny i always wanted to
write a script about this they came to
see our show
and then later they were worried that it
was too entertaining
because we told them it was educational
the show was pretty entertaining
and they were worried that they were
going to kind of be audited like their
supervisor was gonna we don't get it not
audited but you know checked in but yeah
and i know and then we were like if that
happens
we will put on the most boring
production of our show so you don't get
into how often were they coming to see
they came once and it took a lot of
convincing i mean like after a summer of
knowing each other we were finally like
please come to the show it's the the
real testimonies of the witch trials
it's educational i see that that is
educational put like you said it was
entertaining was it like no he
improvised a lot so you made it more of
a comedic thing i did okay i was
straight clowning i was the last show i
ever did
we got in trouble all the time but
anyway that's where i had that sounds
amazing that's where i they would tell
me horror stories about they they were
stateside obviously they're working in
salem big spanish-speaking communities
so they were bilingual yeah and they
just you could just tell it was wearing
on them like a lot of
uh slam doors yeah oh yeah that sort of
thing so why don't you who did you go
with and tell me every feeling because
it's also an exciting time in your life
you're 18 you're going to japan oh it
was it was insane it was i still tell i
mean i i geek out i mean almost should
have warned you like you asked me about
my mission i was just the whole i love
hearing about these things but it was
cause i remember what it felt like to be
and going on trips like that i i mean
and i'm convinced that all young people
when basically once they finish high
school
need to do some form of abroad yes you
know like get out there you know you
know why college students will need to
do the backpacking trip across europe
go on a mission whatever it is
sure i would i would say see the world
of course you know sometimes you're if
you're as a missionary you're called
stateside but you still you're stepping
out of your comfort zone truly look no
matter where you go that doesn't sound
like a picnic to me i've tried to sell
tickets in arizona
let me tell you folks
scott's
scottsdale i had a few doors slammed in
my face let me tell you right now and i
wasn't trying to get the burden in the
bosom keep going and uh uh we uh and
so going to i mean i was yeah i was
beyond excited studying the language you
studied for two months intensively but
nothing that's part of it well so you
have the mtc the mission the training
center for two months if you're
if you're learning another language you
go for two months ahead of time wow and
they have one in provo now you can do it
online they have other places but
um
and then
you know you're you go out there and you
roll in with your brother and you're
like so i did so my brother and i were
there at the training center the whole
time but then we parted ways for two
years because he was going like i said
he went to a different mission it was
our neighboring mission so mission is
like it's a territory i was the tokyo
north which was like northern part of
tokyo and several other areas north of
that and then he was nagoya which was
the negoy area but you know whatever and
part of the rules is you're not supposed
to leave your area you can't see anybody
while you're there yeah yeah which is
fine this is crazy to think we wrote
letters to each other
not only was it not emails or letters
but also the fact that we wrote letters
we were like brothers yes we're brothers
in old english yeah dearest brother what
am i writing how to go with your mission
the right is hard yeah exactly send more
right
so we uh
yeah we um we never saw each other but
like uh twice a year they change it now
again it's like once a week you're
allowed to but back then it was
you mother's day and christmas you're
allowed to call your family
whoa and then i was allowed to call him
as well
um but yeah it was was that special for
you or that anybody
like a twin no no because he was family
and i guess because he was serving at
the same time okay
million questions yeah you train you get
there when do you when are you released
there's a mission already happening when
you get there you misses there you get
there and you get a trainer a guy who's
like already kind of learned the ropes
who's a little bit more experienced but
when i say trainer he's just a regular
missionary but he's he can sp normally
he can speak the language better yeah so
he knows the rubs he's going to show you
the ropes uh for the first couple months
and so gil choro let's say you say elder
chodo
and it goes backwards like son yeah yeah
yeah it's all about their titles like
yeah
yeah oh wow elder that really brought me
back yeah elders yes okay so and uh
and gil so gil choto was his name elder
gill he was he was amazing and he um
yeah he was my trainer and so yeah
you're there but he's a kid too he's got
it yeah oh yeah now everybody's like
between 19 20 sometimes 22 or
or 23 whatever but it's all within that
age range and uh and it wasn't until
about
four i i remember the conversation the
first time i was about four months in he
had already left and i got my new
companion
and i was on a phone call and i made it
through the phone call
with basically understanding the
conversation yes because you are i mean
no nobody ever goes fully like
you think you prepare intensively for
two months and you're like i don't know
what's going on you're listening to
everybody you're like so overwhelmed the
sights the smells i mean
tokyo was such a
culture shock yes i mean it took it was
like living in a i was obsessed in
psyllium with blade runner i was like
i'm in blade runner you are in blade
right this is lost it was like it was
raining neon signs the sights yeah
things floating around
a naked lady bends over and talks to you
and and then yes can i tell you about
another testament of jesus christ
oh you're not real
[Laughter]
boobies
in that case
it was uh yeah it was not far from that
and um
and yeah and now so about four months in
i was starting to feel comfortable with
the language and i could like
before we get to that sorry no tell me
about your first day going out knocking
on doors not yet comfortable on with the
language
and i'm assuming they have a pretty
intricate map they're like we've already
talked to these people
you need to talk to these people right
yes but what's funny is like you know
every area in the mission is assigned
two or four elders or sisters if they're
in that area
so it was just the two of us in this
area and
yeah there's where he's gone and you
have records kind of of what being
covered but how far did those records go
back i mean these are 19 year olds
you're depending on they may have not
marked this or and is there a code
for like
interested but not i'm not trying to be
funny interested but not converted oh no
there's a full shot
while you're there tell me the show well
like it was all in japanese the king
jeans are the keen is gold so gene is
person kimchi is like the golden contest
this person's super interested they're
gonna get they're gonna get baptized
they're on their way okay
you know but that's also like
yeah there's oh man i'm forgetting a lot
of it but yeah but you would have to
have records of like this person's
hostel right i mean that you don't
really have records on people like
like it's just like oh we've done that
apartment building
and you're also keeping up like half of
the time you are in japan especially
you don't have as many you you hear
about missionaries who go i i say south
of border like whether it's mexico or
south america and they're just
constantly teaching the teaching
teaching people are open they're there's
tons of people joining church in japan
you know you don't have that you know
you're just like looking and looking and
being turned down and turned down but
you you don't like it's not
it doesn't get on you because you're
just like i'm learning japanese every
time i talk to someone and i'm listening
how was your attitude well yeah because
you didn't have like i'm not winning i'm
not no like they tell you like look
you're this is where you're going this
is a reality and and you're but you know
you you do your best and you you stay
strong it makes me happy that somebody
wasn't breathing down your neck people
like i don't know i need to you know
dude growing up being evangelical people
would be like if you're not converting
this many people a year oh yeah like
what are you doing and i remember being
like
high school is hard enough yeah like the
few times that i would be like can i
tell you about the most important part
of my life to somebody in a car and
there's always a tent well and and the
mission it's it's the missionaries
they're all like i mean they're people
you know they're just like you're going
to have majime as those really strict
guys wampaku is the opposite and oh
those guys were juanpaku those guys just
go to the nearest electronic store and
they'll just sit in the uh electric
massage chairs and they're i knew guys
on my mission like i'm talking about
elders like oh elders
missionaries like that would blow not
rule followers they're just like ah or
they were lazy at the rules they're like
not breaking hardcore rules but like
look we you have to have type tokyo is a
playground have you ever been to tokyo
no i want to go it's a playground it's
still i mean you could go and get so
distracted of course and there you know
so you hear about those who are like
obstrict and i'm gonna do that but yeah
i relate to that because i went to a
christian college and there were people
there like me that were studying to
become pastors yeah and then there were
people that are like my parents are
making me do this or like they'll cut me
off if i don't do this yeah meaning and
that's i'm not surprised yes oh god same
way it really is it's part of the
culture you're like you know you're kind
of the whole time you're growing up it's
like you know it's just part of you this
is what your dad did and sometimes it's
like you want to rebel it feels more
like pressure and then sometimes it's
like i can't wait to be part of that
family legacy or i can't wait you get
the new converts they're like i'm doing
this i don't have any family members who
are members of the church i just i need
to go and fight yeah yeah and so you'll
get and you see that it's part of the
adventure of being a mission is like
it's really for you it's not really for
other people you are interesting growing
yourself and a lot of times i'll say
that it's really for the missionary to
gain their own testimony or to learn the
value of
loving other people of serving
compassion yeah and patience and
humility i mean everything it's a low no
i'm i'm assuming you're not converting
there must be days weeks
11 people under my two-year
um
you know going there two years 11 people
under my you know teaching that were
technically baptized i see you know i
taught tons of people and there's tons
of people who are like along the way you
know but i was just like that's great
yeah as long as you're like out there
two years eleven people this is great so
um father greg boyle just did this
podcast he started um homeboy industries
it's this amazing i won't tell the whole
story but anyway he said
he's like i don't i don't know if prayer
works but i know praying works
so there's something about that like
the mission being for you like does it
work
well the mission works for the
missionaries and then there's also this
other
component of like the numbers or you
know what it is it's like you know
praying is also when you think of or
kind of what you're talking about there
just
what you're talking about
which is fine that's not a judgment but
we love them i am a stand-up guy what
are you talking about
i like to think of myself as a stand-up
person
but it is it's like you work
you were saying about prayer well more
about like when you go there's you know
you're gonna get what you put in and
what you expect if you're there to
hopefully
no i was like perfectly in between well
i don't want to say in between i was
there to
i like to believe for all the right
reasons i want to go preach i want to
learn a new culture i want to learn a
new language i want to learn what it's
like to live on my own to take care of
myself i want to have fun i want to do
all these things
and that's what i got out of it yeah you
know and we're very similar i went to
venezuela into the jungle with the
yanomami indians and i went to say that
again jana mommy indians it's also my
netflix password so i'm gonna have to
change that gosh dang it i'm just
kidding then uh and uganda so again
these are baby missions these aren't two
missions but like it was looking back
that was about me like we built a house
um the people there there was already
church so there are already people
teaching so it wasn't really
about like bringing home skulls you know
what it means like they say in the
business world like i i or scalps you
know it's not like numbers like we're
nailing it these people didn't ask the
question like i literally was just
talking to my uh sister about like a lot
of these youth whether it's through our
church or other a lot of churches will
send out these young youth programs that
go to these other countries these lesser
you know uh third world the less
fortunate and do these house buildings
very similar and she's like well but
like they don't know how to build houses
and i was like you're like you're
probably right some of them probably
more skilled than others
but a lot like my mission you know
you're hopefully they're going out there
and a lot of times it's for the good of
the youth
the individual because if they think
they're doing good and hopefully they're
doing good for other people yeah
but it sets a precedent whether or not
that house falls apart as soon as they
leave yeah at least
what they've gained is
it feels good to help others yeah no
they i i i wasn't
yeah they say that uh i say this all the
time is what i'll say to my daughter
it's like
learning math in high school isn't about
math it's setting a precedent to learn
something yes
and to finish it even though it's
uncomfortable yeah i wish someone would
explain that to me i think i would have
taken it a little more seriously because
i was one of those like we're not going
to need this sort of people
tell me and again
this is just for out of pure
almost like white-hot curiosity not
judgment what is the strategy for
i could guess for uh getting someone
interested in the latter-day saint uh in
the church of latter-day saints i would
have to imagine
if you meet somebody who's a as i
jokingly call regular christian just
meaning like we cut off at the new
testament um if you meet a regular again
i'm kidding but a regular christian
that's that's a good base there has to
be like a tree graph for that there's a
lot of scripture that is built upon yeah
in the in the book of mormon and also
the what are the tenets of faith the the
the articles of faith the articles of
the faith yeah i didn't think so that
was written for the newspaper but became
this yeah it wasn't published um sorry
little joseph smith fun fact oh yeah
but um tell me a little bit of the
strategy if someone's opening the door
what are we doing well
depending on which mission like for us
you know and and they kind of tailor a
little bit different because they like
we know you're going to another country
and really for us i mean at least back
then this is the late 90s when i went
and it was you know you start with a
base and for us it's not christianity
obviously it's really god you're just
starting with god yeah well and you work
your way beyond that so what's the
opening line do you believe in god do
you have a minute yeah oh my gosh i was
like
and uh like most people said it's like
so most people believe in god or at
least a lot of people believe in a god
but to them you know they're not
thinking god they're thinking a god or
whatever it is so you start just
building from
god and you're working your way up from
there and god i don't even think jesus
comes into it
until like lesson two you know we had
different you know lessons because the
first one you're going for lesson one
just yeah whatever it's always the same
approach you know you have your
memorized kind of like
you know a script
because especially memorized says it's
in another language and you're just like
i can't i can't improv yet
wow
is there a placeholding line if if i say
something in japanese that's really
complicated there must be a line that
you learned to say which is like please
be patient i don't know yeah something
like speak slowly or yeah but then
ideally you're with other i mean but if
someone has already gone that far
to tell you something else besides
you which is i'm good i'm good most the
time they're not that engaging yeah and
they don't want to open up they either
shut the door you know they they don't
even answer the door yes so if you are
already talking with someone that's like
a win and you're like great we got more
than japanese lesson japanese lesson yes
and a little bit of human interaction
yes and an adventure and a novelty you
never know what's gonna happen and then
and i constantly had my little tongo
book tango for vocab because every
conversation you're learning new things
like repeat that one more time and then
you write it down i look i have my
little dictionary i look it up like oh
sweet now i got that buddy i see exactly
why
for a young person
to like
see why learning what learning looks
like in a real world yes yes so like the
first time i went to when i was in my
mission in south america
when we were in uh caracas driving
around i was the only one that spoke
spanish and being able to understand
more than i could speak which was a
weird phenomenon of course i attributed
that to god i was like i understand i
think we're going to the hotel we're
speaking tongues that's part of it
[Laughter]
i think i'm translating the tongues he's
speaking technically
but like
it made
learning real and i right so i'm just
excited for 18 year olds it was yeah it
was it was very
you know i i i mean
you changed i fully
it's what i needed it's what i was
expecting
but also like you don't feel it until
you're you know you're off and
off the mission and and you're just like
yeah i uh i i enjoy school more
i enjoy you know everything more because
is it because of what we're talking
about like you saw what learning is for
well like there's a whole world out
there and the more you know yes it's
sort of easier it is where you're
starting from is faith you're starting
from like this is what i believe i want
to go and share
and i want i want to serve a mission
what would then with that is a whole
experience that comes packaged together
and all these things you got to learn
for me i had to learn a new language i
had to learn how to live with another
person i had to learn how to cook and
clean i had to you just all these things
that come with
that are kind of in the book and you
know it's gonna happen but you're
learning along the way and
and uh i say that all the time all
married people should be single and
alone for a year because you you see
what it's like especially in the
patriarchy like you expect someone to do
the dishes like do your own dishes oh
yeah for a couple years i i still do my
own dishes i'm just saying like because
you learned that no one wants to do them
it's not like oh the women like doing
and no everyone just knows you got to
get the mac and cheese off the plate do
it yourself and they're preparing
because you will have
such a plethora of different
personalities with all your companies
what was your guy like what was his name
which one you're you're not a lot
swapped out well so no so companion part
you have different commands you're
swapping almost every couple months
sometimes yeah it's different for each
mission will be different but you never
have the same companion for the whole
thing i mean i thought
no no i had uh
oh man i gotta count but it's like i had
seven so sorry seven different uh areas
and each area was about two companions
so i had like 15 maybe 16 different
companions wow all at you know different
times but okay i didn't know they they
mixed you guys up oh yeah yeah no that's
again that's what's great because you
will have your favorites you will have
your lesser favorites you will have
there will be fights some people just
aren't for you oh yeah you fight with
any of them i never fought physically
yeah and the one that i probably
struggled with the most was more like
psychological like stare down just like
i see what he's doing he's trying he's
he's using
passive aggressive what what is that
passive aggressiveness i just learned
that word you know tell me what an
altercation looks like in a two person
it was not exactly for me
you know like from my perspective it
would not be exciting because it's just
like it just wasn't the sweetest when i
was the when i was the senior companion
i'd be like well oh what do you think
you know you're always you know you try
to learn to work together and make your
decisions together like a good couple
should and you're like yeah all right
well do you think we should go down
there and do some uh pass up some
chitashi's which is the uh
little flyers yeah she's passing out
flyers
and he's like well i don't know what do
you think we should do that and you know
and it was a little bit uh
it was just like
okay let's do it just like i'm not going
to deal with this nonsense
like
insults within compliments kind of those
i understand that kind of thing and was
there holiness
competing like who's
kind of like holier or like more i just
remember it could be like
talking to somebody else they were like
the way i did my mission is is you know
heavenly father told me where to go and
like so if you were like should we go
over here it's like
you know i'm i'm kane and kung fu like
i'm waiting for a message from above and
i don't know what is he saying exactly
like that that's who i would have been
well he's telling me to punch you in the
face right now
here's here's a question uh honestly
note the time because i'm not even
trying to put you in a corner no no i'm
i'm i'm open for you whatever i'm going
to say
when you're an 18 year old because i was
an 18 year old going on missions again
only for three years what is the
[Music]
you're the horniest you've ever been
john oh yeah and when i was that age all
of my spirituality came down to whether
or not i was masturbating that that was
the entirety i was holy if i wasn't and
i was going to hell if i was and here
you guys are alone we joke that you're
in a it is an erotic city and i studied
a semester in jerusalem
there was an adult bookstore literally
like made like a star wars it looked
like a star wars cantina it was an adult
bookstore i was always like
so represented just trying to get catch
a glimpse of of a boob or something yeah
so like i'm not trying to trap you i
don't know you're talking to a brother
i'm like
i loved god i loved god yeah and i was
earnest and i was horny as [__] oh yeah
and i'm just wondering what
is the jerk-off situation where you
because here's why were you shrouded in
guilt was it something people talked
about
tell me well it was like
the obvious answers like yes of course
like you shouldn't be doing that and you
like
and it was i will say it's like
i think it was on the mission the first
time
i had a wet dream and i had him multiple
times and i think well that stands the
reason i mean if you're if you're not
saying it yeah it is like
oh what's happening you know it was like
it was confusing right well yeah and it
was just like oh man and but also like
oh
oh what what happened to that dream
again if i can only remember hold on to
that you know i guess you're like man
that was great and like he's the only
poor no you were saying yeah exactly
and i've got a great imagination my my
mind can whip up some amazing stuff yes
of course but yeah like you know you
you're there and like any mission you
know they say they always joke like what
we would call like you got your mission
goggles on
meaning wherever you are the ladies are
gonna look great
yeah because you're a missionary and
you're away and you're going through
that to like you could be like it could
be the most unattractive it's like no
you've got your mission
you see it but you know of course being
christian being a young missionary yeah
they tell you to lock your heart
which is even cure well that's all
that's almost a difference
there's obvious there's the obvious like
obviously you cannot have
relations sexual relations or any
relations while you're on a mission you
know you reframe for that
um but then the whole lock your heart is
kind of like you know
lock your heart try not to
fall in love open your heart to to
romance yes to even if it's not sexual
or whatever it's just like you've got to
focus just do your best to focus yeah
hard to do though right did you struggle
i did i i was i was great and i saw and
you know there's a little bit of like
i'm pretty good at this now i was not
a popular guy growing up in high school
i did not i had one
girlfriend before me too
and barely that she doesn't she doesn't
know we dated but we we dated
no i was like
all right you know i know it's gonna
happen for me one day today's not that
day man you were able to do that
too like i mean like refrain from
i'm not just i was jerking off but like
just
it what like for me even three weeks was
like this is a lot but i would do it and
then i'd come home and just go
no
but you're on two years yeah no well but
you're not like yeah you're just like no
we um
you're just like no let's let's focus
let's focus that worked i mean you just
killed yourself to do it yes
you're just like team to 20. well you
know when you get a prime jerk off yours
you're in the prime of your career you
you you know i didn't have a lot of
practice before so it wasn't like i had
like a bar that was already set dude
i wasn't at peace with it but it was
still happening
you know what i'm saying like i wasn't
like i am now which is very liberal
but like back then i was always trying
not to but when when you're in those
situations i guess i'm trying to have a
conversation about okay i guess
yeah i'm not saying no it happened
it happened i'm i'm not gonna lie to you
but it wasn't like i mean
you know
did you feel horrible well
horrible
no because i was i like to think but
surely even at that age i was like
i shouldn't
and i should and you know but i also get
it's like these natural urges
i don't feel bad for feeling bad about
it but i also don't feel bad for not
beating myself up about it i understand
it's kind of a mix
somewhere in between i was like no just
keep focusing it's always about it's
that concept like i'm gonna keep messing
up i'm gonna keep messing up and
whatever it is
just as long as you like you know
acknowledging you just keep going
forward and just keep trying was it
something that the guys talked about no
uh
because we didn't talk about it either
no no i've talked about this many times
i i found someone's journal i feel bad
that i read it and in it it said i
sinned again today and we all
the pages are stuck together oh no
[Laughter]
what do you mean
in the journal come on
they see a picture of you next to it
you can see why i was like i'm not
trying to get you no no no i see my
relationship to god especially at that
age was just so
it's easier to be a spiritual person now
that i'm 43 let's put it that way yeah
because when i was 18 it was just like
so much so many fireworks were going off
inside of me it's pretty interesting
that that's the age and what's
interesting it was almost more like i've
grown spiritually
and so i was different then but it was
also all pistons firing in
in on both sides yes you're horny and
you've got hormones and all this stuff
but you're also not putting yourself in
situations yeah you're not hanging out
with uh girls you're in if you do i was
like no i'm not gonna ever that's part
of what you're changing like we just
don't do these things we don't put
ourselves in these dangerous situations
so i'm not going to feel it and it's
fine but at the same time like i said on
the opposite side it was like all
pistons firing spiritually i was like on
a high high yeah i was that feeling
that's what set me up you were feeling
wet i was feeling that like
that immediate like went i was feeling
the spirit i was feeling the spirit
constantly as a missionary they say
that's what you strive for and i did it
you're you're feeling like you're out
there and you're you're praying and like
okay guys and you have those miracles
you have those experiences well tell me
some tell me some mission stories if any
come to mind not of a guy carving into
his arm and stuff those were wild and i
don't think true
but oh i would believe it would you oh a
hundred yes tell me some missions
another thing we all joke about is like
every missionary will tell you
like their mission has the craziest
people because missionaries just draw
out the crazy and and when i and not not
trying to be insensitive but you will
talk
the most interesting uh doing finger
quotes interesting just some very
mentally you know mentally interesting
like interesting and some
and you know because they're willing to
talk yes and you will talk to incredible
people who are
genuine beyond belief and want to learn
more and then you'll meet people who are
just starving for attention and you just
need to talk all kinds so this is church
by the way
at church there's a certain
element
that is attracted to a as anyone would
be a group bound by forgiveness and love
yeah so if you're kathy the kooky lady
that no one wants to talk to and your
family disowned it's sort of nice that
you can go to church and be loved but
that doesn't mean kathy is in cuckoo
conker's cookie box
just literally probably two years ago in
an airport and um
i was lit i was working there oh no
and uh i think i saw you people like
yeah it's a great time
and uh
me and my buddy had met this nun uh a
catholic nun and we had befriended her
we were talking we had lunch with her
and she was it was so interesting i love
it i loved meeting people of other
religions and really just getting and
talking about some of her experiences
and we were walking down the terminal uh
in between
and just this woman
out of nowhere this younger woman like
walked right up to her and was like
sister and she's bawling and just like
i'm so sorry and so like she was like
basically i mean it was kind of a
drive-by confession and she just you
know
she brought her own beads
whatever they do it through and and she
was i think she was trying to confess
something but she wasn't getting into
specifics it was just so
quick but it was really powerful just
kind of see i had never been exposed to
that you know yes growing up in a
different monks priests nuns the the
public
i don't say costume disrespectfully but
if you can tell by what you're wearing
people will be coming up to you for sure
and now so if you wear the nun outfit
they're going to confess you if you wear
the elder's outfit they're going to just
like hey and like
here's check out my markings on my arm
we're like no it's
it really is no i mean there was um oh
man i would i do not encourage throwing
mountain dews at the latter day same
missionaries that was a riff
no they will be very grateful because
they got quick freak reflexes we ride
around everywhere on bikes we got to
know what's going on caffeine and they
now they drink caffeine do they now well
yeah that's gone i thought that was out
no that was like the quick thing on that
was it was never real it was never a
commandment or never like a rule was
always kind of more like
a lot of people believe like it was no
we don't drink caffeine and the profit
number of years ago
i mean this is like i don't know like
five six seven ten years ago when he was
like
kind of like look it's fine
yeah yeah like i mean like anything
there's just like nothing that's too if
you're addicted to it then maybe you
shouldn't be drinking it but you know
what i liken it to is like um
you know how it says in the in the old
testament not to eat crabs and stuff
you know what i'm talking about
yeah
yeah crab roll uh certainly have had
crab in my life but they were like
there's some wisdom to it these things
are eating all the [__] like literally
eating [__] at the bottom no when we
think about it why is this so delicious
it's not a hard rule but there's
something true to us but anyway um we
have two things going i do want to know
what people get wrong about um the
church of leonard isn't and i want so
we'll get to that but tell me these uh
you were saying people always think
their mission has the craziest stories
what were your stories and what were the
stories you heard well i didn't have
um
oh man that's a good one because i you
know you almost killed it well it's it
was hard to remember some of the crazies
because their japanese was nuts yeah and
a lot of it was when i was in actual
tokyo because a lot of my mission was
outside of tokyo it was north in in
tokyo a big city like that you're gonna
get like some interesting people
but i mean it was also just like all
right they invite you back to their
little apartment and you go inside and
then they're pulling out food that
you're like
what is this i was part of my training
team and part of being a missionary they
always say it's not hardcore but even
from when you're a kid i tell mike it's
like you got to eat what they give you
you don't want to offend them yeah and i
i did that early on and you're just like
oh gosh oh gosh like oh no like what do
i got to eat here and so yeah there was
like a lot of crazy stuff away but i
don't nothing like spiritually odd
nobody like having convulsions some sort
of no i never had that no like spirits
that like or demons that needed to be
exercised yeah um
uh you know you hear you know you start
talking obviously other missionaries
either stories from other missionaries
or just from their youth especially
missionaries who are from utah because
utah
you know where the ba not only the base
of the churches but that's where you get
a lot of the skinwalker stores and boy
that what are those skin walkers you've
never heard of skin walkers you know
skin walkers what tell me everything
well it's just another it's basic okay
this will excite you navajo witchcraft
get out of here that is no it is what
are you saying
it's like don't look at me and go no
witchcraft
that was sweet i wanted to see your
action i wanted to see if that kind of
person where you get erect a little bit
when you hear that you're like oh that's
exciting it's a little it just looks
interesting what's a skinwalker
skinwalker it's novel it's like it's
like witchcraft it's navajo witchcraft
duh um
no it's like i feel like every culture
is like when you think of voodooism when
you think of uh all these devil
worshipping and different but yes i
don't even know if like they were you
know considering the devil but just i
understand evil
becomes a catch-all for evil but i guess
the best way is like we're talking like
shape-shifting like stories about people
seeing
full
blown like like deer that are running
and then they stand up and turn into a
man
uh like i'm not giving a good justice
but it's really cool don't you
oh yeah and he still poops little
pellets yeah uh the transition isn't
complete i'm still kind of i'm still
digesting a little bit
it's those little babies
but you're a man yeah yeah but you're a
man my five didn't transform i still
have the tail it's just okay
but you're saying utah as a place is
like one of the more they just had a lot
of stories coming out of that yeah
because you're gonna
i feel like the culture runs deeper with
whether it's
and how much it's true but like
met old members telling stories about
you know getting rid of you know evil
spirits out of the house out of a person
yeah and and not just church stories but
like you know just demonology yeah and
that kind of stuff
and i believe that i've if i believe
in christ if i believe in god i believe
in satan and therefore i believe that
evil spirits can't exist and that
that's why paranormal activity was a
freaking scariest movie i didn't care
for it i know it was so scary it was so
scary but
i mean it was it's cheap and lame but
i'm also like putting myself in those
shoes i was like oh my gosh that's just
yeah terrifying to me yeah that movie's
sort of a napoleon dynamite in itself it
probably cost a very little amount to
make and and very well good segue right
into it
let's go into it yeah it's still up oh
it's up we're doing double
the first one wasn't good i know the
second one was you just left this up a
little feather
um okay so have you ever seen a ghost
because here's here's why
when i was in utah you're reminding me
yeah i did a radio show
and they played i really wish they
hadn't but they said that they went to a
insane asylum in utah and they're like
utah's one of the most haunted places in
the world and this is the story they had
turned the um
the insane asylum into an attraction so
there were people dressed as ghosts oh
yeah it was like a haunted theme park
they do a lot of good haunted like
themed stuff over there but it was
supposed to be a real haunted place but
to make it a more consistent scare they
got actors to
haunt the place for a living wage
and then the woman uh when this woman
goes up to the manager and goes like
this child there's a seven-year-old girl
crab walking backwards down the stairs
it's inappropriate for you to have
a seven-year-old girl working here and
he goes of course there's no
seven-year-old girl working here she had
just seen a ghost
amidst all the i feel like that's part
of the job is he has to say there's no
seven year old like
you guys they bought it
that
is
razor right there like most likely
that's part of the fun is it'd be like
there's no he does it eight times a day
if there's no seven year old if i was a
ghost it depends on what the ghost's mo
is like if they're like i want maximum
you know uh
exposure i'm gonna come out when there's
all these other fakers and nobody will
believe or that's the best way to do it
that way that's good thinking that's
good ghosts thinking what are they
thinking like that no i've never seen a
ghost no you gotta have seen a ghost
face really oh yeah
has it between me you and katie who's
seen a ghost this face
you look like you're looking at a ghost
over my shoulder right now no i'm not
i'm just looking at your
giant ears
they'll haunt you hold on oh they'll
haunt you okay so no weird uh mission
story no ghost um uh we're jumping to
this have you ever almost died
then we're gonna get to your comedy
career who cares
exactly i really i mean talking to
somebody that's on a mission that is
really fun and interesting to me but um
have you ever almost died uh no not like
a near-death experience like sure living
in japan and riding on a bike sure i got
many times it was always like it's not
when it's it's not if you get hit
in in a in a bike accident it's when
because if you're in your background so
we rode bikes everywhere and yeah and i
got clipped a few times nothing like i
mean luckily i was you know
i was protected um but uh yeah no
nothing
i've never been in uh
no okay no
what do people get wrong about the
church of latter-day saints of jesus
christ um
well i'm not even gonna say magic
underwear john
but i just did yeah
but i know the stereotypes
are you wearing it yeah is that real
yeah i didn't know it's not magic i know
but tell me what it is but it does
magical things tell me everything about
your underwear you just gave it a little
glimpse yeah yeah and you're wearing
whenever i wear shorts i'm just like oh
i gotta hide a little bit like that what
is it called nephilim the garments the
garments garments
garments
the garments the garments yeah we were
garments the garments yeah let's say the
garments the garments and was that a
later revelation or is that a joseph
smith uh that is a no no that's uh that
that's from when they started building
the temples and re-instituting in like
uh the temple stuff and it's part of you
know when you when you first go through
the temple
uh at a certain age you can't do it
before 18. or actually i guess when did
you do it it was when i received my
endowments they call it is when i
prepared to go for on a mission
before your mission so you had these yes
during the does it go up into your
upper body it's just like a t-shirt and
oh it's just two pieces yeah it's just
super yes yeah and it is for protection
well i mean you could say spiritual
protection it's a reminder it has
symbolism to it uh like
like kind of you know a bunch of things
kind of in one sure um you're not alone
uh it's funny you're not alone in terms
of other faiths that have
clothes yeah that they wear i knew there
were some jehovah's witnesses i talked
to that told me they wore
scratchy sweaters
it was it was it wasn't like a precept
it was something that these guys were
doing because it kept them conscious it
kept them present because they didn't
want to be comfortable when you're
comfortable you start to start to stand
up to like they wanted to title hands or
scratching on something and they they'd
use that as a reminder to stay in the
moment and to stay thinking about that
that's the same reason why where i can't
stand wearing it
well it is wool it's 100 when you're
living in california you're like oh i
just need one less layer and there
you ever just wear that to the beach or
something like an old-timey just it's
out there it's like
we hike it up sometimes it's a one-piece
search you can get one piece it's a
single how does that work yeah that's
what i thought it was i thought it was a
you can you can wear it you can get all
kinds is it a whole business you go and
buy them somewhere
yeah you can buy them like online you
can buy them at the temple and yeah you
get them yeah you just wear them yeah
all right
very frodo when he got stabbed and they
were like look who's wearing this oh
yeah that's right or whatever sometimes
people have those amazing stories i wish
i had better like near death versus like
[__] it let's get to comedy
bullet wound uh this one bounced off why
because you're a rock hard nipple nope
nope my garments my garments yeah but my
rock hard nipple deflected the other
bullet
you're hdn
um okay so take me from
being
i'm going to say it a sweet
uh fun-loving adventurous
occasionally jaying it mormon missionary
yeah
to um napoleon dynamite your first your
first break what what happened there how
did you get into comedy because you're
so naturally funny were you were you a
funny fella
i think that was actually a part of the
transformation was actually kind of on
the mission because you really find it
surprising a lot about yourself yeah
so before so i think the easiest way so
before
i grew up really into art and my twin
and i we were big at you know in drawing
and just so we had the creative you know
kind of uh bug there
and then it wasn't until like middle
school and high school when we started
making videos and i was like i wanna i
wanna get into films this really i dig
it what was the movie that did it
well
so growing up having watched all the
star wars steven spielberg stuff e.t
goonies you know obviously yeah kind of
that stuff
so yes exactly yeah but it really was i
think i'd already decided but when i saw
jurassic park in the theater yeah and
like like freshman year of high school
we just rewatched that raptor scene yeah
get the [__] out of here it's so good
and out of here and when i and still
like
that it wasn't just that there was a uh
a number of other films that probably
around that time really high school was
like in the 90s you know there were some
great films coming out and i was like
okay i want to make movies i want to
make movies and yeah so
did you make them with like a camcorder
yeah we had to start my dad's camcorder
every opportunity we had to shoot a
video for a class project we would if
there was a secret if there was a book
report if there was a social studies
video yeah video video because it was a
guaranteed a plus
and then some yes extra credit yes
because teachers loved it teachers loved
it we had we did white fang book report
and i had we had a siberian husky that
was white fing we had a japanese
exchange student who was every other
indian
oh my god no terrible really yes of
course
your area hard to find yeah we're like
we've got a japanese successor let's use
it perfect yeah yeah okay dog is not for
sale that's uh i was still quoted to
this day
doug is not for sale oh
my god we loved
japan it was great no i could finally
speak to him yes oh you looked him up
yeah we of course i had to i was like
now i can like speak to him in his
native language and he loved it he loved
it oh the subtitles are on you cast me
as every indian in your dumb movie
okay i thought this was going to be more
fun i was like i recorded it back then
and now i understand that you sucker
yeah gratitude buddy look it up
there you go very nice awesome um
so so any opportunity to make a little
film you will yeah we love we love
making uh videos so
naturally just when um we did a year at
byu before we got into the film program
we were like we're going to do this then
go on my mission and on the missions
really when i found
my
during high school when we make videos i
was not in the drama club i was not
doing the acting stuff but you would be
in your own videos you know just goofing
around and so i think that started to
come out like i like to be goofy i like
to mess around and every video we were
in it was like trying to do comedy and
just be stupid yeah and so i think that
really got accentuated in the mission
because i was alone now i didn't have my
twin brother around me i could really
not that he kept me back but it's like
i'm this is how i stand out you know we
would do put skits on at christmas time
we would do i had i bought a camcorder
when i was there i made videos there and
uh
so that really became like and that i
kind of became known for that on the
mission just the animated guy like just
kind of messing around and being goofy
yes and being made of spaghetti just
like literally
like you know
i was obsessed with jim carrey you know
and of course and so
after the mission uh
you know we roll in in byu get back into
the film program start taking film
classes and one of the classes was
obviously we have to take an acting
class
and i was like okay and and we take it
and it just it clicked it's like i loved
it i i got it i understood it i was like
okay and it was almost like it had
always been there but now i'm singing in
class form and learning some of whether
there's terminology or some of the
methods i was like this is great
removing the mystique a little bit yeah
but not but in the in a great way like
okay
i can i get this
and i remember being young and thinking
acting was for like special people like
you had to be like a movie star yeah to
act well and i did i did like acting
camps like in in grade school but i
didn't have
i do remember the switch where i was
shyer and i didn't know how to project
or put myself out there on stage it was
still a little bit like you know kind of
pulled back and reserved but it wasn't
until the mission i was able to kind of
like
find that confidence i'm not surprised
at all again when when
john came in were like this is meant to
be yeah very similar it's like the
church was my safest place to start
performing
it gave me stages there were yeah uh you
know youth retreats or whatever it may
be but it was also kind of like a safe
and loving environment to like be
yourself yeah but then it was like also
combined with this very real world
go to venezuela like go try and order
decaf coffee in the caracas airport you
know what i mean and i'm like
sin caffeine and they had no idea what i
was talking about it wasn't for me by
the way i'm not a monster but but all of
this stuff was
let it giving me a safe place to find my
personality absolutely and and you know
you you go to byu's this kind of it's
just an extended mission to some sorts
like where
i was now
doing what i wanted to do i was studying
film but it was amongst people who had
you know
generally the same beliefs the same kind
of um but not just the beliefs it was
also kind of raised the same way yeah
come from very similar backgrounds you
were comfortable yeah can i ask you
because the film programs at gordon i
went to this christian college regular
christian
regularly
well lower i call it lower uh two book
yeah yeah you can call it two book
christian gold christian i love that
i'll be your servant
[Music]
um
but
we uh
the film program was a little lacking
because we couldn't have
a conversation necessarily about pulp
fiction or something like there were
things that were naughty and and we had
professors who
i they were pretty open about like we
have professors who would talk about it
all they probably wouldn't they weren't
allowed to like show certain films but
they would certainly talk about it or
maybe show scenes and it wasn't too hard
core and but i think there's so much out
there that they could cover i think what
was so
amazing and at least i don't know if
it's our justification or what we
believe but we're like
because we're still making films here
in a college that's still you know
essentially owned by the church or um
then you know we can't make
you know rated r material yeah we can't
do certain things but
we none of us were really interested in
doing that and it forced us to be like
all right we gotta really get creative
and think outside the box and do
different things i've said this a
million times uh but howard stern
i think
either he said it or some people have
said it's like when he was restrained on
terrestrial radio that was kind of the
golden age of stern is because they had
to play in this box and when i was being
funny in the christian
box it was i was probably being more
interesting i'm not saying i'm not
interesting now yeah but now i can go up
and be like you ever see a dick that
looks like it has a whatever you know
like yeah yeah like and that's fine and
it's funny but when i was really and i
think that is where you get a movie like
napoleon dynamite now that i'm thinking
about it well i think that's exactly it
here let's go to a quick break we're
going to go to our mid-roll ads and when
we come back we'll finally get to
napoleon dynamite which i wasn't going
to we're going to talk about it as a
product
of
this kind of restraint yeah we'll be
right back
part of the interruption weirdos this
episode is brought to us by uh maybe my
favorite new pete's pick which is real
paper i mean
it's wonderful that we have toilet paper
at all remember when that was a problem
but trees are pretty great wouldn't you
say i mean they provide shade they make
oxygen which we need to live they
prevent erosion they suck up all that
carbon they provide homes for animals i
mean is there anything they can't do and
to turn something as awesome as a tree
and more accurately a forest of trees
into toilet paper has always to me just
felt super super wrong these trees spent
decades growing only to get cut down and
literally flushed down the toilet i mean
even the tree from the giving tree get
to give out a few apples before they
turn their branches into a house it's
weird this is why i love real paper real
r-e-e-l makes a sustainable toilet paper
that uses 100
bamboo the great thing about bamboo is
it's a fast-growing grass some species
of bamboo can grow up to three feet per
day and because it's a grass they're
able to harvest the same stock over and
over without disrupting the plant or the
soil and on top of the ecological
benefits of using bamboo reels paper
packaging reels paper packaging is
plastic free and compostable it makes so
much sense we've been using reels as
soon as we found out about it full stop
i don't have to remember to get it
because we subscribe and it just shows
up it feels great i'm gonna say it it
feels great on my butt
two it feels great to know that we're
not wasting trees why were we ever doing
that when this was an option real paper
is available in easy hassle-free
subscriptions or one-time purchases on
their website all orders are
conveniently delivered to your door with
free shipping and 100 recyclable plastic
free packaging so if you head to
weirdo realpaper.comweirdo
sign up for a subscription using my code
weirdo at checkout you'll automatically
get 30 off your first order and free
shipping that's r e e l p a p e r dot
com slash weirdo or enter promo code
weirdo to get 30 off your first order
plus free shipping so let's stop
flushing our forests and try
real's tree free paper reel is paper for
the planet and show your support for the
podcast back to the show
and we're back go ahead
yeah
i love it that was
weirdly it felt like three minutes is
that normally how it was i had three
minutes of dead time just now we just
sat here in silence in my mind for three
full minutes yeah dead silent just like
staring and waiting for them
and you're like now you push me with
your
shush right up against my lips
covet tested he's clean it's fine
okay so tell me what that makes you like
the napoleon dynamite from this
conversation's perspective now really
seems like the kind of idea
that grows in exactly the soil we're not
going to cut people's heads off we're
not it's not going to be about sex it's
not going to be about profanity this
isn't a time when we're starting to see
the apatow kind of wave right or is it
it's before no this is
just before i mean freaks and geeks had
come out right
and well like the raunchy grown-up
comedy yeah we were still kind of going
through uh a spell where rated r
comedies were not as big yeah yeah they
were on the cusp like they went through
that wave and then it wasn't popular for
a lot of the 90s and then it was
started coming okay soon after but so
how did this come to you so kind of what
we were saying before that said with
those kind of restraints you'll either
have filmmakers they're like you know
being a critic already as a film student
we would see our peers work and like
well that's pretty lame and you know
like that's not great or that is
brilliant now
soon after
getting in a few years in i met jared
hess
uh who wrote and directed napoleon and
at the time you know we were just in
similar classes and um
some not similar but we were in this uh
directing class together
and i think
it was just
it was it was built and meant to be you
know it was like
it was the perfect combination because
he
he grew up there and it was just his
story in preston idaho
and
so so many similar uh similarities in
our background he was ray zelde us he
was he had a lot younger brothers uh
grew up kind of in a cr what you call
crusty household where you know you
you're using different words to express
your anger instead of curse words or
whatever yes so
to non-lds people especially
reads as quirky interesting yeah like
lo-fi fun yeah yeah not but to you maybe
it was like this is funny it still felt
like it still felt familiar but still
quirky because like i was still
surrounded by you know i always heard
that language yeah whatever
um but when jared came to me you know he
i had done one other project
that i acted in that that my production
was like my intro to production class
was like a you know mod intermediate
production class
and they needed one person for this film
that we're all putting together and
they're like well john you do it
and i think it was just like class clown
kind of vibe like okay you've seen the
goofiest you like to mess around let's
put you in it i think it was just that
that was the only thing i had been in
wow jared must have seen it he also we
were in the same class so
it was a big class a lot of people so he
must have been observing me somewhat but
he just comes to me with the scriptures
a character similar to napoleon in that
or were you just being you i think it
was just being it was more being me uh
but i think just in
when i was not acting just me in general
probably talking about like oh like
my frustration sounds like napoleon and
if i was pissed
in traffic people are like are you doing
napoleon it's like it gives it away he
was doing me yeah yeah
and so he was like dude you like read
the script i think you'd be good uh it
was for the short film that we did yes
and the second i read it i was just like
oh my gosh yeah this is like so
not obvious but i was like yes
this is what i this is this is
i get this this is what i've been
looking for it's that same kind of
um
humor sense of humor but we hadn't seen
it portrayed this way yet yeah because
he approached a lot of his early stuff
with this really nitty gritty um this
gritty kind of approach where it's
partially because we had no money so
he's shooting everything on black and
white 16 millimeter film and it's gonna
make it look kind of crusty but it it
helped it instead of like trying to make
a colorful
um you know high school comedy and
crisp and clean we were like no we're
hanging out with these kids we want to
make it look like it is a home video
that they're shooting or someone is just
hanging out with a little bit of shaky
cam or a little bit of a like wide angle
lens and everybody looks a little bit
uglier than they really are
um
and i loved it it felt personal you're
like yeah you know yeah i don't look
that weird yeah you guys don't forget
wide angle lens and the wig did was it a
wig no wow no okay
whoops
i'm just kidding but the hair the hair
didn't know the best one was when i had
a uh
someone interview me like a press went
out to the movie came out she's like how
did they do the buck teeth
as i was like wait what are you talking
like what she's like you know the teeth
how did they do like you know those big
and i was like wow how'd they do those
ridiculous teeth and it was a phone
interview so she couldn't see me go like
covering my teeth like um those are mine
and she i don't even remember how she
covered i was like you suck
okay
breathing heavily it's like what i used
to call uh like sears to see if like a
toy had come in and they'd go sorry
ma'am it hasn't come out yet and i'd be
like thanks a lot ma'am and i'm hanging
out
what are they talking about oh
my farts don't smell like urine why do
they keep saying that oh
[Music]
that's cause that's what boys say to
like uh
dude whatever man
you far smell like piss like you're just
queefing that's not like real farts i
was like oh come on i'm not a chick i'm
not a chick dick queef i've never heard
of a dick queef like as if like your
your farts smell like urine because it's
really come out it's really yeah you get
oh i didn't have to explain i'm sorry i
thought i had to explain no i think i
felt so seen and loved that you didn't
explain it
i you did explain it it's the best thing
you can say it again it's like no man oh
his farts smell like urine man
wait and then it takes a while oh no no
no that's not no that's a real fart dude
check it out no it's coming out of my
butthole you idiot
it's coming a straight butthole there's
no
there's no vagina farting here today
well that would be a real queef yeah but
that's what i needed to wear a penis to
queef it would smell like peepee yeah
depending
so okay so this is the dirtiest i get by
the way i think i knew this was gonna
happen
like we this is why i said it was meant
to be we
yeah yeah i was just gonna find it yeah
we'll find that just where
yeah
um okay so you read it you shot it on 16
millimeter film in black and white
and then
when did that go like oh we should turn
this into some oh wait before we even
get to that how did you build that
character what were you basing it on and
all that it was so it was there on the
page but really like i read this
it was without like a lot of the
physicality but like it was it's like
okay he said it but jared
if you
sorry there's a funny moment just before
this if you want to note it while you're
in the bathroom
she can hear us it's a funny dick queef
thing that i think might be worth noting
and cutting everything else out
just all we really just a one minute
episode adds one minute of dick queef
more ads then it comes back to us and
we're just laughing about dick queef
dweef adewif now i just made that up i
knew you did we
it was sort of on the page yeah
so it was yeah it was on the page but if
you knew if it's i don't know if you've
met jared um
but he is like a master like he all the
characters he'll do himself
and he's this really animated guy and
he's just like the second he did the
voice he's just like well i picture him
as this guy who's just like
listen up flip an idiot i don't want to
do it and everything was a little bit
more lippy and a little bit more
exaggerated but it's still
i was like yes that's me and my younger
brothers yeah like whenever they're
pissed whenever they're annoyed that's
just that's them so i just like that's
it that's a boom everything this guy is
it's just this constantly
crapped on younger brother type who's
just like oh
yeah just he's the sound he's that
through chapped lips yes
mouth breathing yeah kind of crusty kid
who thinks clothing dragons reality is
too much yes yeah and well the eye was
kind of a weird mix of just me
and i squint a lot and also he's just
like yeah we're shooting in the sun and
everything's and it's like you blocking
out the world he's just like too much
it's just
sorry i've been doing it now but it's
just like it was just it was natural for
me but it like made sense for the
character it was so easy yeah and you
know we just yes yeah and and jared and
i i will say we went to the d.i i don't
know if you like but in provo i like the
deseret industries that's their um
goodwill you know it's just where you
can go get second-hand uh clothing
everything so we went to the local di
and we just started going through
clothes and we just started like oh he'd
wear this kind of shirt this got a sweet
ninja or a sweet dragon on it with these
acid wash jeans and then simply it was
like he mentioned the moon boots i was
like sweet i remember having those
and then his wife
um was like
and this is the best part this is like a
day or so later after i said yes i'm
gonna do this short which was a two-day
shoot and preston it was like no big
deal yeah but
before that she's like called me up and
and because they they worked together
and did everything so jerusha his wife
she was like john what do you think
about it a perm
i was like and i was single
and i was like
you know i was like okay i'm a post
mission i want to like start dating i'm
not good at dating i don't know how to
but i like girls and i want to get with
them and i don't think a perm is going
to help me
but all this
thought process it's going to be harder
everything i just told you was a
millisecond where i
thought that and then within the same
millisecond i was like
dude who am i kidding
you're never going to see another
student
here who's not even officially an actor
i'm not a paid or a professional actor
but you're not going to see another
student do
make that kind of commitment for student
film and i saw what level jared was on
and he's going to give it a disallow i
was like we are going to kill it like of
course yes and i was like yeah
absolutely let's get a perm
so
i got my friend who was a hairstylist
and she gave me the best perm
of your life that
ever that i have ever had but it was it
was tight it was amazing i still tell
people the perm and the short is
years better than the one in the film oh
really oh yeah it's so good because by
the time we shot the film
we had someone else do it they didn't
they did it wrong so we had to re-perm
which fried my hair is just a mess so
what happened between the short and it
becoming a feature i mean so we did the
short and it was awesome and we got it
in like slam dance which is like
sundance adjacent in the same place but
it's the smaller version yeah
and that was like that might have gotten
into a few other film festivals but the
point was is like this
this is a short yeah and we love we
loved it and i s to me it was perfection
um
and people were digging it like the
local kind of indeed well the film scene
at byu like people got it they loved it
but you know i didn't know how far that
was going to go and it was like maybe i
don't know maybe a few months later that
jared calls me up he's like dude
what do you think about doing a feature
next
it was like the following summer so we
shot this in like fall of 2001
and then
2003 is when we shot the summer of 2003.
so he's like he had about a year and a
half like i want to shoot a feature
of this
what do you think i was like yeah of
course on game like why would i say no
to that yeah and he originally he what a
lot of people don't know is like he
wanted it to be just the same kind of
vibe but different characters he knew
you wanted to call it napoleon dynamite
because the
the black and white the short one my
name is seth and there's no
he just knew he wanted his first feature
i don't see seth dynamite making 44
million in the theaters or whatever yeah
and uh that's a big mistake
seth isn't working
made it into the film i didn't okay
but
he was like he originally talked to me
was like what if we like shaved your
head and gave you braces and he was
thinking of
another crusty kid from preston idaho
but wasn't the same but then we did the
sh oh and then that's right he had
talked to me before the short really
came out then after the short and he saw
how well it worked
and it was kind of a test that you know
a lot of directors would do that he's
like no we're keeping that character
yeah it works so well don't [__] with
seth yes and then let's we call him
napoleon dynamite news new name and then
we're just gonna where'd that come from
so he on his mission
uh get out yeah he was on the streets in
chicago came across this guy they start
talking about like
hey i'm elder hess he's like oh elder
jesus starts talking about like well
it's a title we go by this and he's
explaining the name so what's your name
and he's like because like that's
interesting you're talking about like
interesting names well mine is napoleon
dynamite shut up he was this like shut
the [__] up when you're talking to me he
was this weird italian guy but get this
i don't know if a lot of this is even
crazier we found out later
that napoleon dynamite was
is like a pen name
that elvis costello used on one of his
albums
what
back in like i think it was like the 70s
or 80s so
i think this guy was a big fan of elvis
costello yeah or
knew someone who was a big fan it could
have been you know yes uh uh
hand-me-down through generations this
name
jared had no idea of that connection
he just like that is the sweetest name
i've ever heard i'm writing it down
because he knew he was going to be a
filmmaker he was like i'm going to make
my first film called napoleon dynamite
wow and then that's how and then where
and then that guy walks away and he
turns into a deer and runs off they're
like it's kane
but he's just but he's still pooping
human poops and you're like the
transformation there's something they're
dropping you just give us deer poop
instead of human turtles i would much
rather poop little skittles yeah little
poop skittles yeah yeah they're easy to
clean up and you don't even have to stop
you ever see a deer they just keep going
it's just walking
and there's no way breadcrumb trail no
wipe it's like leaving a terrible
breadcrumb trail for your friends
terrible not that's fun it's not as fun
but still but unless you continue to eat
it and not find your way home trail i
was just like
my human turds couldn't get you from
here to the kitchen
just one
spot and it's more like it oh he did
make an x out of his turns you do what
is under here you mark a treasure with a
human turd you make a trail with a deer
turtle the trail leads the human
turd different for different needs and
if you make a typo at a typewriter bird
if you need to loosen the dirt you just
urinate on it
and if you fart and it smells like that
it's called a dweef
this ref has opened a portal a portal
for which no one returns
i think we just keep ripping katie just
has to leave she's like gross i'm
smelling it i smell it i smell the urine
i smell your dweef
um okay that story is incredible banana
and then yeah we shoot the movie 2003
um not a lot of bread right you uh no no
not like but i was just for the fun of
it it was for the fun of it it was like
i was i mean i was happy it was a
thousand dollars america's like yes
luckily and uh i was like uh i was like
sweet yeah that's fine any back end
uh
no not no i wasn't sag
i was not with anything yeah
and the producers were kind enough after
the success after this film sold at
sundance they like john we're going to
throw you a couple points they made oh
they did okay yeah so they made good
that's a
likely
yeah
know well you know we're lds i was going
to say we do that you know that bro
for the lds right there um well and
these guys were friends yeah these guys
are uh jeremy [__] who was a producer on
it his brother financed the whole thing
so his brother is very happy
um and uh and yeah we imagine yeah
that's a lot of x on your money yeah you
made what
you were saying and we made
no so we made the film yeah and um
yeah i don't know it's like that brings
us up to where we're we're coming out
well there's quite a bit oh yeah yeah
yeah that's comfortable
it's covered let me ask you this was
there a lot of lolling on the set
because it seems like one of the hardest
movies to shoot without laughing i'm
also going to preface that by saying
that valerie my wife who you did not
meet i met you met briefly yes she was
on her way out though uh so it was sort
of right
we
i'm sure you get this every day of your
life but the one that we say every day
is expressed
placed explosives okay like you
accidentally ordered that no no we say
it or if we do that when you're thinking
ahead to what you're gonna say and
you're gonna say expedite but and you
blend it into the word before but when
that was in that movie it was the first
time i had seen it like in clearly in
the script it's such a funny moment was
it it wasn't no oh you just [__] up
that was
you know what was so funny as i
literally told that story today someone
asked me about it which is so rare but
what so the script i'll tell you this
the genius are you seeing other podcasts
michael
rosenbaum oh you did and bombs yeah that
was yesterday yesterday yesterday yeah
but it was after that that we talked
about anyways
he um i'm giving you a second to cut
that out because i don't want to mention
michael
i don't want to say i don't want to give
him any juice no no any jew just a
german dude yeah i know i'm like you get
so used to that under armour
is that your under armour garment under
armour under armour armand armies
undergarment garment armor under armor
garments under uh undergarments under
armor garmin undergarments are you
wearing your mormon undergarment
underground under armor garment you will
still get a like oh yeah here you go
check it out um here's the eternal smile
what is that sometimes they like the
scoop neck i call it the eternal smile
oh my god sometimes they're crew cut
yeah sometimes well if it's a v you're
like
a straight for uh reverse hoodie hoodie
could you imagine like people like i
can't breathe what were they doing i
just saw a kid wearing the hoodie like
that the reverse hoodie yeah and i was
like this kid's figured it out yeah they
figured out life yeah your parents will
tell you where to go you don't need to
see [__]
which is great
okay so oh oh yeah yeah so
napoleon explains he he wrote every
every line of talk people ask a lot how
much did we improv it was no improv it
was like every line was scripture like
we which was like this is perfect this
is the kind of the cadence you don't
want to start riffing it just wouldn't
match the vibe it's almost like a piece
of music it was it was just like you
want to nail every single thing but then
when we shot that scene it really was
like i think jared was like okay i want
you to have a current event about lake
loch you know nessie and he i think it
was a loose script
it was no it was there but it was more
like the the flub was not in there and
it was just like you say a little bit of
this but it was the only time jared was
like just make up some stuff just you
know just keep going because i'm going
to have one of the kids
interrupt you with the laugh or like
yeah yeah right
i'm going to kill that kid you know that
kind of vibe so
yeah that's just i think i flushed
displaced
plastic spoons
place explosive detonators at the bottom
of lake loch ness to blow nessie out of
the water
so core godfrey of the nessie alliance
some of the help of scotland's local
wizards to cast a protective spell over
the lake and its residents and all those
who seek for the peaceful existence of
our underwater ally
and all the red the last half of that i
just made up and just like but the flub
i the second i flubbed i was like oh
we're keeping it i know he's just
because napoleon has to be frustrated
yeah like because he has it perfect but
he messes up
i love his it's an interesting thing
how do you enjoy
i mean you're delighting me
it's so fun it's like being a magician
or something you can do that and bring
instant joy to people and i was very
curious to see what your attitude is
towards people
wanting a little taste of the sweet
sweet well it is like
through
you know i went through
in the beginning it was it was it was
crazy i think as you can imagine it was
just like going from zero to 60 and
everybody was like like so into it and
dealing with fame and dealing with like
whoa okay this is new
but i i still looking back and i will
always remember it's like this is a good
thing like people loved it right and i
think
tom cruise will say show me the money to
people just to give you a parallel like
i'm always fascinated by this without
being prompted i think like if they're
like hey show me the money he'll say it
back yeah and i'm like that's awesome
that's a real showman yeah but you're am
i hearing you right maybe there was a
time where you were like i don't want i
was always like mr and this is why it's
kind of like you know we haven't really
gotten into it and maybe we won't
but i and this may be a total segue i
recently watched all of crashing and i
got oh you did love it yeah i love it
that's great yes thanks man and and i
did because i just worked with jamie and
i was kind of like oh what has she done
and then i was and i don't and i know of
your stuff but i was like i'd always
started crashing um but i was like i
watched it all and i was like
and i was like
and that's what was great about this
because i was like this is great i
relate to so much of this
so much like business stuff i'm not a
stand-up comedian but like oh my gosh
there's so much and i honestly after and
this recently we shot this i watched it
i was like
i never do this i was like i'm gonna i'm
gonna dm pete i just feel like i gotta
yeah did you i didn't because that's
also like but i was like no i'm going to
i was just lazy but i don't dm anyone
the whole time i was like oh man i'm not
really on there and i didn't see it i
was getting an apology no no i was just
like no i i was like i should i should i
i should and then and then michael
reached out and i was just like this is
this is like oh you watched it before
you knew we were going to do it yeah
yeah no that's and also because you just
didn't sleep with jamie lee that's why
and yeah so i heard it and i was like i
was curious about it and then jamie and
i was like okay i'm going to watch it i
was hooked yeah i loved it thank you but
i'm telling you it was like i watched it
i was like
this is like
like there's so many parallels parallels
so many you'd be shocked at how many
people related to especially that my
character was religious and was trying
to break into this there was there was a
religious aspect there was the
the lust for like the happy guy because
i was like yeah you were so sweet and
kind of i'm like it's not a brag it's
just like i've always been very positive
and very like hey yeah just like and
there's an innocence there but and
trying to hold on to it yes i think
people are very interested in that yeah
i think you know there was like also
dealing with the fame i was just like
okay
i love that people and i love it would
have been so hard if i didn't like
napoleon the movie and the product today
i love it and it's you could be the guy
from the room tommy
or whatever like who has to deal with
people coming up who maybe think it's a
joke yeah yeah you know what i mean but
everybody it really does seem to be like
everybody loves napoleon dynamite like
well
and the good thing is if they don't like
it they're not gonna approach me
but you still i think everybody you know
i'm sure you've had fans who's just like
you know i don't think you're that i
don't know maybe they don't right but
you will i will get honest people as
long as they're in company with someone
else who likes it yeah they're like well
it's not for me
interesting
and then i tell like no no no just go
watch it again you could watch it two
more times hilarious because i've
learned that weird
people like it's like anchorman in that
way the first time i watch angerman i
was like
that was my second that was my like oh
my god
big lebowski for me yeah it was the
first time i found a deep appreciation
for big lebowski how many times have you
seen it i've given it a few tries for
some oh man i i don't i'm going to tell
you why i don't tend to like characters
that are stoned and just can't get it
together i would get i get yeah i mean
like you watch a lot of stone comedies
but smoking pot then none of this he has
the same name as you
no one has to lose a toe because you're
like oh well honestly man you know it's
like [__] get it together it was like
i don't like pineapple express
no i know yeah oh i'm not i'm wrong but
yeah i think i liked it i remember
seeing the pi uh the pilot the trailer
for napoleon and it got these weird
laughs i've never heard before because i
think it was you going over the ramp no
no you're like
no i just remembered the audience in
boston having no idea what to do with it
it had that like you know the organ and
and you're just trying to go over a ramp
yeah i think it was just a locked off
shot of that yeah it was just like
napoleon dynamite and we're all just
like what the [__] you know it's boston
right nobody what was that what the [__]
was that napoleon light you mean elvis
costello's pen name
his gnome diploma
dad you're yelling
uh but i i remember even being like i
have to see that just on the trailer
anyway uh we're going to jamie and and
and go on yeah and so i would i just
went through this period where a short i
it was i was always cool on the surface
but there was starting to become a
little bit of like
like with the not so much with the
family but kind of moments of like i
like
why can't people i started to see with
fans people
doing
not acting like i think people should
act
like you know what people might like
like why do they have to like
i think it's because i never was
starstruck i was never i never grew up
around that but i was always like no you
respect people and you act cool around
them and when people are like kind of sh
you know fans are fans there's the great
ones and there's some who just do
asinine things or would people shove you
no no like but be chubby about like okay
oh you got to do this or or hey you
don't like my voicemail yeah or whatever
it is it just seems like there's being
cool and then there's you know you're
not really being cool but it was a
phenomenon and you had to deal with a
lot of that yeah and so you're saying if
i'm hearing you correctly there was a
time when it wasn't that groovy to be
have people yell napoleon an element of
it but it was just having to deal seeing
a side of people that i wish i could
educate everybody like
like don't don't approach me that way
don't come up or the it was like how are
they what would it give me if someone
was taking video of me while i'm at a
restaurant eating i was like that's so
rude and people i i think that's part of
the core of like my principled
um
personality of like people should not
act this way people should not be this
way and if only and i wish i could
educate everyone yeah and like you know
it's not malicious it's just
ill-informed it's just ill-informed
they're not thinking about like you as a
person yeah and it was also like you
know i go to a party and i have a great
conversation with someone and they were
like
uh and they maybe be a friend or a
sibling to a friend of mine and we're at
a party we're having this great
conversation at the end of the party
then my friend comes i was like hey uh
yeah sorry i know you're leaving but can
so and so get a picture with you and
then i was always like i tried to
analyze every single interaction was
like dude we just had a really great
one-on-one conversation why do they have
to turn it and make it now i felt like
it was almost hero worshiping
and
it was a weird
humble way of approaching it but also
like i was like don't put me on a
pedestal and maybe it felt like oh yeah
you felt you were trying to keep it i
was almost felt like they were putting
on me you wanted to keep it close to the
earth you were just having a nice but i
also felt like prideful about like
feeling
like i was being put on pedestal so i'm
like no they're not seeing it that way
so there's a lot of torn kind of
feelings but
i was letting it get to me
um but it was it wasn't ruining my life
it wasn't like taking me to a dark place
for the most part i was very happy to
accommodate and to and to humor people
whatever but you know when you can't go
to disney world i mean it would be hard
for you to and that was a good example
of like sometimes i'd be like and you
know especially in the early years when
i started having young kids and i'd be
in the middle of like come on like oh
crap they just pooped their diaper and i
gotta go they messed and and then people
come up or or
i remember being on a plane once and
just i was i was really sick and i was
like and so we were getting patient zero
for code right what your patient is zero
for code this was no this is like ten
years before okay but i think it was
that was not me it was monkey it was
monkey
and i was getting off the plane and i
was so i knew i visibly looked like
death yeah and this couple comes up as
i'm exiting you know the the plane
they're like oh my gosh like hey so like
can we get can we get a picture of you
it was it was the first time ever
actually said because i i was always
very nice and like tried to be but i was
like i'm so sorry i feel i'm so sick and
i i can't take a picture right now i'm
so sorry and just on the nicest i was
like i mean if you have like a pen or
paper i could do an autograph like oh no
we don't it it's fine like so sorry you
know yeah feel better yes cut to
three minutes later i'm waiting for my
wife because she was in a different seat
and so i was still waiting there the
couple comes back with a paper and
pencil and they're like can we get that
i was almost like i was being like kind
of nice like i feel like crap
so it was just examples like that which
just happened every now and then yeah
could you sweat on this yeah
but then i don't know it felt like it
was like 10 years ago
suddenly i don't know what it was it was
honestly it was a click of just me
mentally turning flipping a switch
you're like i'm not gonna let it bother
me anymore it's stupid it's i mean there
will always be you know idiotic fans or
doing things that they don't realize i
don't care anymore i know what everybody
says you know if you can bring joy to
these people well that's what i was just
experiencing is what made me like i was
shocked and i'm not like an obsessive i
pro i probably have seen it you know
a good ten times but yeah i know you
know people that have seen it hundreds
of times yeah but like
it instantly brought me joy like like my
daughter if she sees balloon animals or
something yeah so there is something
nice to see
but i also like the boundary that you
have you know it can be both you can
have a boundary and a and a time and a
place for things yeah but also it's
really fun to see but i'm trying to like
turn off like that i'm not going to try
to educate people anymore i'm not going
to try to yeah
lecture them on or or even in my mind
lecture like oh this is what i should
have said yeah i'm just like look some
people are like weird either i avoid
situations but for the most part i love
it because i do see that i see that joy
and i see that immediate gratification
of like yeah like they love it i mean if
i could feel how i felt i think i i mean
you're already you're already there but
i'm like this isn't fake it's like i'm
really having a great time when you did
your nessy speech and i was just like it
it ties it to a nostalgia and all these
it made me feel like i was a kid again
like it was really great it's like we
say a magic trick because you know
there's the people
we working in the industry you've met a
lot of people you've probably geeked out
about yeah it is the same thing you're
like especially with when it's someone
and i'm speaking on
this behalf where
it was a quotable movie and it brought
people back to a certain time
and when i see
if i see patrick stewart if he's if he
goes
engage yeah like
of course you know i hope he does every
once in a while like please and you know
you kind of have that but
you're like i'd rather have just a nice
conversation with someone that i respect
but how great would it be to sorry
to get if you're a trekkie
you get a trekker that's what parties
yeah my brothers called ourselves we
were trackers not trekkies yeah because
we didn't want to be lumped in with the
trekkies i understand trekkers were cool
trekkies all right so if you're a
trekker and you're at a star trek
convention
and you dweef
and you arrange it so that you propose
to your girlfriend and then as soon as
you put the ring on you turn and patrick
stewart is there dressed as jean-luc
picard and he goes engaged
that is oh my god i mean that would be
the greatest one
she's like
and then he gets beamed up and then he
gets beamed up which would be incredible
but then the cable snaps he was like i'm
sorry it's not supposed to work this way
number one this didn't happen in
rehearsal
uh two questions one
what did you think about the kanye lyric
i mean when kanye did uh a napoleon
dynamite i mean that's i mean you know
cool right yeah i guess you know i i
love you pretty cool huh yeah people ask
me that i was just like yeah i mean
like i didn't listen i've not i've only
heard the song once really yeah i wasn't
i'm not gonna tell me nothing i can't i
would like they're just like hey they're
using it i was like all right i guess
that gives me points with the young
crowd even though i was still young at
the time yeah like
all right yeah i mean if kanye said what
you know about green eggs and ham i'd be
pretty excited but i understand there's
not much to say about it yeah let me ask
you this uh because we are in the last
moments here at the show it's been
wonderful this has been a day off for me
uh i say that when i get to just listen
to the podcast yeah i didn't feel like i
had to
work oh good uh so thank you
what it what is it
what does it mean to you how are you
finding a a faith and show business
balance and i'm not asking that from a
pious place i'm just curious you don't
live in hollywood yeah you've done
amazing things none of us are dan rad
but i mean like you've had you played
the glory all all of these
amazing films and voice over and
directing but how are you balancing it
with
something that isn't really
like a a an lds movie star when i first
heard teleview was sort of like talking
about like a a jewish unicorn or
something like it was just like there's
a jewish the regular christian unicorn
yeah the whole unicorns for the most
part are regular christians they're
christians that's christian mythology if
you look it up
deuteronomy
out of gethsemane revelations there's
all kinds of creatures out of the
unicorns
um tell me well it was uh and i'm not
asking that from like a judgy place just
because people ask me that yeah they go
you're a person of faith how do you
blend it i'm more interested in you
finding a balance of being a spiritual
person that feels a connection to your
creator yeah and a business that's like
look at john heater he has a pack of gum
give him 50 grand just say he likes that
gum like that's not great
[Laughter]
as long as this double bubble that
specialness that showiness of show
business isn't necessarily i'm saying
always great when you're trying to feel
at one with the world exactly and see
everyone as your brother when you're in
gifting suites at sundance you can feel
that you're like oh this is why in the
in the desert uh the devil uh
tempts jesus with money yes power yes
fame yeah these are the things you and i
have embraced so like what do we do
that's not a judgment no no no i think i
was equipped early on to have like a
sense of humor about my faith and when i
say humor i think like a place where i
could
like objectively kind of stand outside
i've always tried to do that in my
personal life
for you know empathizing and
sympathizing with anybody any culture
whatever it's like you just i always
tell when i go do youth talks or
whatever i was like i feel like the
secret to life and possibly happiness is
is perspective you know if you could
just
walk in the shoes of another person if
you could just stand outside yourself
and and because it's it's the secret to
you know eradicating pride and erratic
you know and getting into a place of
humility so
solidarity and compassion yeah
and having that
ability to and i'm not perfect i'm
saying like
you know i will plenty of times step
outside of my own shoes do i always get
the perfect view or do i get fully
educated no and i'm always trying to do
that but
when when it comes to yeah the faith in
hollywood yeah going into hollywood you
know y'all i always made that joke like
oh hollywood is the den of satan and it
is where you know dreams are made but
it's also where you know deals are made
as well
but not really obviously believing that
i wanted to come in and make a
difference but also the difference was
like prove to myself like
i want to do this i want to make movies
and i want to i want to push the
boundaries a little bit they always say
stay away from you know in in youth
growing up as lds youth it's kind of
like that idea of don't get too close to
the edge of the cliff you know like know
where the boundaries are don't put
yourself in situations
and i was like i think
i didn't hopefully i didn't make the
mistake
uh or you know the choices what you see
other people make or like no i can i can
handle that close and then you know they
fall to temptation or they fall whatever
it is
but i felt like
i wanna be in that world but i also
wanna i want to just simply
it's not just one this is what i believe
i'm going to continue doing this
and i'm going to do my best to make it
work but i had no
guidebooks i mean there's not like a
community you're an un
uncharted territory yes very much and so
it was like all right i gotta just
follow the spirit and the story though
would by right should have been
john heater sort of like crashing it's
like not that my character lost his
faith but he had to redefine it yeah
yeah he started meeting people that he
loved
that he used to would have thought were
going to hell but he saw the god in them
yes he saw the lava yeah the beauty in
that that spoke to me
i knew you you're that kind of person i
can tell
but um the story should have like you
know most people would have predicted it
would be as soon as you made money yeah
and as soon as you were surrounded by
people who weren't in the church that
you would
you know yeah marry an actress get a
mansion
probably start doing drugs you know what
i mean and we see that off of who's
backs yeah what did you have in that
story i saw you doing it off of a duck
actually oh a duck's back
ugh like duck cocaine
decayne that's what makes me so daffy
yeah okay
yeah i mean you know i i
played out all those scenarios but it
was always like yeah i'm not interested
in that i knew from an early age i
wanted to have a family i this is what i
believe i want to like live this way and
you know i don't want
people to think and or myself to believe
like i got to get out of la because we
you know as you said we just moved and
it wasn't so i need to get away from
hollywood it was more like i only got to
get away from the heat i just
literally it's too hot oh is that right
oh it was a big a big decision
katie before he got here i was like i
bet he has a
cool weird reason for leaving l.a no no
not here it is hottest and there's
traffic
i thought it was corrupting your soul no
it wasn't it was really like i i'm a
very visual i just like i grew up in
oregon and i love the pacific northwest
i was like i just want to raise my
family in a place where
i don't know like
i always had an image and you know and
and part of that has come true and it
really was like i just want to be a i
don't know a pacific northwest dad yeah
no i can kind of doing art and doing
acting on the sides and going but i want
to be able to see trees yeah
it really was more of a physical thing
but
uh and i was very sad because i left
some people behind my uh my brother who
lives here and obviously a lot of
friends which means a lot of people
think you live here yeah yeah they're
like although i saw a photo of your
brother different different vibe yeah
yeah right uh i mean tuttle's fatter
yeah
no he's great he's he's different vibes
slim down let's see slimmed down beefy
yeah
i actually thought i saw a photo of you
guys and i was like the these are these
have different i meant it as a twin
compliment yeah yeah yeah i said the
same thing no if you met him and our
kids
stare at us every time we're together
because they love seeing this weird
mirror because even if he looks a little
different the vibe is pretty much the
same has he ever started napoleon for
halloween i mean no he would never sink
to that he would never sink to the level
let you out i'm gonna be my brother
standing
you know and like larry i'll punch you
in the face because he's slightly older
i mean he's like three minutes older
yeah see yeah i can feel that so um what
are you sorry no no just like going back
to the balancing and like yes i don't
know maybe i covered that but i i think
you did yeah sorry
no sorry this is your time baby
we i i haven't had an lds guest though
so i'd love to ask what i asked this to
everybody what do you think happens when
we die
well
let me get into uh discussion six in our
series do you vie for collab um um isn't
isn't colab a thing that is like deep
stuff that i think like that's not
that's not what
yeah it's not mainstream i couldn't even
give you all the answers to that yeah
and i'm not saying it's ignorance but
it's not what's important no i
understand that i said i have kidding no
no but it's like
yeah no i you know i believe i
definitely believe in the afterlife i
it's still not quite certain to me like
they we talk about like not spiritual
prison but like the spiritual
um
like
whether they're waiting and you know we
aren't giving all given all the answers
like while we wait i do believe in the
second coming i do believe that we will
be judged and we will um
and that we are saved but based on um
you know
that everyone will be saved that we will
be resurrected i believe i believe it's
an axe there's something that all are
resurrected yeah we will i i believe we
will all be resurrected there's a
hierarchy right my father's
mansion has many rooms sort of thing
yeah a little bit of that but i think it
really will be like
even the lowest level
is
you would if you saw it you would kill
yourself right now to get there it's
that much better than earth now i see
kind of any so those are the sons of
perdition is like the lowest right the
lowest you know is
kind of what we talk about outer
darkness like sure i guess you could
call that hell but when i talk i mean
it's like we're talking you got to be
really evil
like like you're evil incarnate i don't
believe people it's hard for me i i've
always struggled with thinking people
are evil they are terrible evil acts
right that you do and well the
conversation of ethics and
accountability and like culture and like
you're you're part of a thing and you're
just responding to all this impetus and
the way we work it's another
conversation i'm i am and i'm not gonna
charge you with explaining evil
um
but it's i i had another lds person
explaining to me that they were like
even a
non-mormon someone who never was
baptized in the church would still
be in a heaven they would just be in
like a lower heaven even if that yeah
like i believe that everyone
everyone will know the truth
whatever that truth is everyone will
have that chance to
accept it
or not even though i'd feel like if you
know truth is
um and you're dead and you're like but
i'm back i think i'll accept this now
like i don't think anybody will suffer
anybody will like i mean unless you are
like truly have decided to be
you know yeah no i don't know it's hard
what about it's shrouded in
mystery but i do i believe that there's
afterlife and that we will as they say
we can be with our families forever and
yeah and it's
exciting it's beautiful yeah i can't
wait let's do it now together
let's go give me a shirt finally a viral
video
[Laughter]
that's real that's fake it's just it's
just doctored man
that's an after effects chapter i know i
actually i'm not a uh latter-day saint
obviously but
um i do have literally i deserve you
look at my joke in utah as i go they let
me in the temple and everybody laughs
uh i laughed yeah i know i see uh i have
a whole 10 minutes i do in utah but um
hilarities good club anyway um
what i'm trying to preface it by being
like i have some pretty interesting
ideas on whether your inherent divinity
for example yeah um i believe in katie's
inherent divinity i believe in
everybody's i always say like word drops
of water and a way of thinking of it as
god is is the ocean but god is the
animating principle behind all things
because god is a metaphor for being
itself that's what i would say so we are
so we are made of that that being yeah
the i am that i am that moses
encountered um so i say that i give you
sort of like a far out idea in quotes
for
ar where are you on the as we are god
once was as god as we will be
is that a mormon idea or is that just
some people yeah the idea that
there
god exists in that and he has a body and
he has an image and and fro and i i
believe strongly like you know our
entire
our entire life and when i say that like
me lds in our community you know you're
taught these things but there is i i
truly believe there's gonna be so many
things
whether it's after the second coming or
after we died that are gonna be revealed
that like
oh that's what not that we had it wrong
but there's just so much more mystery to
be revealed but
and so however that's interpreted i do
believe we are created in god's image
and therefore and part of this
you probably heard of like the plan of
salvation and this plan that he has for
us that he has a plan for us and and
part of the
the biggest thing is to get back into
his presence to go live with him again
and to become like him meaning
to learn what it's and that's the whole
inherent like divinity of families and
and learning to have be parents and
learning to
create ourselves while on this plane
and in the next life is sort of continue
creating
to doing children is sort of like a
little taste of what it's like
absolutely creating is a little taste of
what it's like to be god these these
things are available to everybody yeah
not not just uh having kids but creating
yeah engaging and making something new
that wasn't yeah and and working our way
to
be like him yeah
it's interesting i think where and i'm
not trying to drudge up differences i
think our difference is that i'm like
i think that's sort of available now
yeah and i wonder if you do too maybe it
just comes into a different
manifestation
in after the second coming as you say or
after you pass uh and you go into the
afterlife
but i i think
what i'm saying is i think god is is
here
now looking out our eyes sort of thing
like i actually tried to find where it
is in the bible i think it's in like the
gospel of thomas so it's not in the
canonic gospels but uh whoa
here we go but people say it all the
time the kingdom of heaven is within you
um i'm pretty sure that is the gospel of
thomas
can have we won't say look here look
there here it comes it's already here
and men do not see it so i have a
feeling of like
when we die
it's not another
well
buddy let me actually say i have no idea
i know i know as i started thinking
about that i was like i don't know the
difference between us you're you have
you have these different images and you
have these different images but it
really has feels like in the last
couple years i'm it's not that i'm
questioning those images it's more like
expanding upon like the idea that i'm
not getting more informed but i
i'm
expanding
my process of believing that
it will i think it will still come out
looking different than what i hear that
can imagine i can't even comprehend if i
even try to for a second i mean when you
try to comprehend eternity you know we
go cross-eyed yeah and and it's i think
that's going to be the same for so many
things well one of my favorite eternity
things is eternity doesn't mean never
ending time it means no time
yeah so i was just watching something
rupert spyro was saying about this it's
like
human beings are like refractions of
light so god is the light and he reflec
reflects himself like through a prism
into something that's called a human
being and the way that time that the way
that eternity looks to that refraction
of the eternal the way that eternity
looks to that refraction is time like
that's how you perceive but eternity's
always here yeah the way we're just
perceiving it through these things yes
yeah so it becomes constrained in the
same way we are constrained and when we
die i know i've gone across it i know it
gets nuts that's really where you are
the way we talk about these things
differ is i when i start thinking about
death
or heaven or the afterlife i see that as
the removal of all duality meaning it's
all one or it's all zero meaning
i i drop the language of like and
there's god in his body and here's me
and my body it seems more like a
smearing of everything into
you know as u2 says all the colors bleed
into one thing that's just my
symbol system that's my metaphor that i
use but as we're sitting here i'm like
neither of these are either more woo or
wacky yeah i mean it could it mean
have you ever done psychedelics no
no that would be interesting never
that'll be interesting that would that
would be interesting
i don't know if you would like that will
be interesting after he leaves that uh
liquid test yeah i forgot to tell him
what's in there yeah some liquid
something else in there it's a liquid ld
life after death
this is what it's oh i can fly those can
those substances can give you a taste of
that oh yeah
you hear about all kinds of stuff that
i'm just like you know what i'll wait
till yeah yeah i have to conjure it on
my own that's interesting is when people
say they know they don't want to do them
i'm like we all have that experience
whether or not it's before you pass her
after you pass but it's kind of like you
were saying the truth is revealed to
everybody yeah and i'm not saying lsd or
whatever or these substances always give
you the truth sometimes it's just a fun
corn concert
let me ask you the final questions and
we'll get out of here um
one is there anything that you wish i
had asked that you were waiting for me
to add no okay great two uh
have
what is the time in your life you've
laughed the hardest
or one of them
and to broaden it and to give you some
priming maybe you're a kid maybe with
your brother maybe somebody farted maybe
somebody fell down
[Laughter]
who are you with even if it's not a
story
uh who did you do a lot of laughing with
or who do you do a lot of laughing with
oh man
um
you know when you you laugh hard with
buddies
obviously um
maybe i'll bring it full circle just to
keep the theme because there's countless
times i've i can remember laughing so
hard but
i mean there was
i'll bring it back to the mission and
and
having those
brothers like my my favorite com well i
shouldn't say that in case any of them
are listening but one of my favorite
companions yeah my very last companion
you know who you are jebsen
[Laughter]
um
uh no um elder roberts from uh new
zealand and we were really good friends
uh and we i just love him
and um
you know just when we mess up you know
you you mess around you know you're in a
place where
when you're young you can you find those
moments to laugh the hardest because
you're when you're on adventure when
you're doing
high octane things you i don't know how
many
life threatening activities you've ever
you know experienced but sometimes those
are the times because you're feeling
almost that like abandonment of
this is not normal and and and i'm out
of my comfort zone so it's only
prefacing that because it felt like the
whole mission you're just kind of like
i i'm like i'm a kid i'm here living
alone with another kid what are we doing
here so you're always messing around but
i just remember one of the
uh
hardest i left was just
we were doing our nightly prayers
together we do a companionship prayer
and
i you know again i had a sense of humor
about all that kind of stuff i i had a
reference
for things that were referenced but i
like to mess around with a little bit
yes and it was his turn he was praying
and i just thought it'd be funny if i
like we'd always like kind of pray like
leaning down and so
uh while he was you know his eyes are
closed he's praying and i like i'm
loving him
like right like as quiet as i can and
he's praying and like get right right
right up to his face i could tell that's
what you're gonna do right after his
face just like i'm like holding my
breath so i don't give it away and he's
a bigger guy than me
and he uh
and he says like amen and i hang out i
think yeah and yeah so we're just saying
it together he says amen and the second
he like just peeked his eyes open before
he even registered me he registered
someone was there and i was like mid aim
and he just
it just hit me so hard
i flew back onto my futon because that's
why we were sleeping i just flew it felt
like a body's like like forever just
whoa like hit the thing of course yeah
he went to fight flight freeze and he
chose fighting oh he's just like whacked
me and i didn't know we had never been
in that situation
and i was sitting there laying down just
in shock and the second he did it he
didn't even register like are you okay
he was on the ground laughing so hard oh
my god and then i started laughing
but after like the pain
but you know even through the pain i
knew i was fine and uh we it was a good
hearty hearty laugh he smacked your name
tag yeah yeah and there was a number of
times
another i just love it so much i laughed
why i like
my it was also on the mission and it was
uh my
uh another uh he was from australia it's
all from the down under uh countries and
we're riding our bikes you do a lot of
mess around on your bike so we just
messed with each other and he was really
good at riding bikes and he was fastened
and we were just riding along and um on
the streets of tokyo and
and just one of the things i wanted to
mention was that where
i go every time i was like we're writing
and i get closer i was like dude check
this out and my plan was to hock a big
loogie and shoot it right through the
spokes of his front tire just to like it
was stupid it was a vital funny it was
dumb it was like so what if it hit this
i was almost maybe i'll spray everywhere
or i don't know but i was like check it
out and he was a little bit more as i
said before the majime type he was very
strict and i found that with a lot of
australians the australian machines were
very strict
and yet he whenever he was around me and
my brother because my brother also
worked with him in the training center
and he loved us because we could pull
out
that
like
shelf that like you know strict part of
him and bring out a little bit of that
smile and that humor that was we knew
was deep down yes
and so
and it was always fun so i go check this
out i go
and i go i just hocked the biggest
loogie
but i don't know what i was thinking it
was like his hand was right in the way
and he just went all over and his hand
was on the thing
he just covered his hand
covered his hand in this giant slimy
and
the same thing he was in shock and but
it was more like he's just like kept
looking and i immediately almost crashed
my bike because i was laughing so hard
because i was thinking this guy probably
thought that's what i intended to do
like hey check this out i'm going to
spit all over you
like watch what i can do
how dare i get away with it yeah but i
was like i just was going to spit
through your smokes i'm so sorry
his reaction was the best because he's
just like
wow that's uh that's cool peter
good job
he didn't even talk he was just froze
like okay he didn't even wipe it unless
the less he talked the more i laughed i
lost it lost it too fantastic
i'm so glad we got to talk so much about
your mission i was clearly sad i did not
expect that i love i don't talk about it
little napoleon yeah what about will
ferrell he ever crack you up oh he did
but in a d you know
i
he was
he was just like
i always say like he was the cool senior
and i was like kind of the nerdy
freshman and just like yeah but that he
was like come on come hang out with me i
was the cory haim to his uh charlie
sheen okay lucas
felt like that like it was just like he
was he was so nice and kind yeah and
just easy to work with and he would
crack jokes but he was also like kind of
all right we're doing doing our job but
he was also laid back enough that we
like can laugh about guys on the crew
and stuff yeah but very funny it was
more i was just like what's it you know
he's one of those people though like if
he was just like hello i'd be like yeah
oh my gosh it's just like hey what's
going on yeah exactly
well john this was oh last question why
why don't you like being called johnny i
was joking about that you can call me
whatever you want baby
on the phone petey do you ever go by
beauty oh i love being called people oh
i don't mind johnny i have like one
friend who like johnny john johnny and
uh and he's my he's my best so okay your
favorite so it's it's reserved for him
you bastard don't ever call me johnny
all right you have yet to go to the
afterlife but i feel
like i feel like we're gonna get there
let's do this let's go down
rapture here we come
if you went up
that would be viral right here just hold
on to my ankle
we're allowed a plus one yeah there you
go
a fan i got a family i got it i got a
lot of people doing come on hold on no
forget them
bell can suck it
let me this is interesting you don't
have to do it as napoleon i'm gonna let
obviously off the hook but everybody
says keep you keep it crispy at the end
that's how we end yeah would you say
keep it crispy and then we're out
keep it crispy
and crusty
you did it
i said don't i
oh you said you were almost like
suggesting to do it well of course i
wanted you to and i'll do it because we
just didn't talk i want to bring you
that but then i was like you already did
it i want to bring you that second of
joy
in an otherwise miserable life
this one got in the
what is it
this one got into a patch of turnips
this one gets caught in an onion patch
this one's perfectly fine it's just milk
it's awesome
very good well done
i'll give you my favorite line though
go ahead the time machine yes and he's
like
hold on i forgot to put in the crystals
it was like extreme close-up of the
crystals going into the little slot oh
my gosh
that kills me
i forgot to put in the crystals
thank you so much john this was a
pleasure yeah
get out of here oh okay
[Music]